each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available um all right um let's start
our afternoon session so our first talk
is um virtual machine res at
vulnerabilities and hch cryptography our
speaker is Thomas wart from UC San
Diego thank you you guys hear me y okay
uh uh so let me just start off by
summarizing um what I'm going to be
talking about today so the first thing
is is something that's that's kind of
bad and these are what we're calling
virtual machine reset vulnerabilities
and so the basic problem is that uh say
you have virtual machine you take a
snapshot and now you resume that
snapshot on two different
occasions the problem is that as we'll
see software ends up reusing some
cryptographic Randomness that's gotten
captured in this uh snapshot and this
can lead to catastrophic failures of of
cryptographic protocols that rely on the
randomness um so this is this is pretty
bad and then in the second part I'm
going to talk about something that that
is better is good which is what we're
calling hedge
cryptography so we're going to
particularly try to address uh this
fragility of the cryptographic protocols
to the reset um Randomness or to other
uh types of Randomness failures and so
the idea is to provide um you know
Frameworks and and for showing that you
can take uh cryptographic operations
like routine operations like encryption
or signing uh and make them more um
secure in the face of increasingly worse
Randomness and so we'll get into that uh
uh kind of in the second half of the
talk so there's joint work with a bunch
of people the first part joint with
Scott ulick from
UCSD the uh um hedging cograph with lots
of different people Mi here barari zika
bki mon gilev HOV shakam and also
Scott so let me uh start off by
recalling a bit about Ram number
generation and and what's going on with
it because this is kind of the core of
of everything in the talk so we all know
cryptography R number generators um very
important and in general in in practice
they're kind of
implemented Loosely in the following way
you have some Ram number generation
process that is going to measure some
hopefully unpredictable events such as
you know keyboard uh presses by user or
Mouse movements maybe Network or
operating system interrupts this type of
thing and then extract from these uh
measurements some hopefully uniform bits
that can then be handed up to some type
of application that uh needs the
randomness so unfortunately there's been
a long long academic literature
showcasing various ways in which this
type of process has failed us and so I
won't uh talk about all of them I can
just remind for example of uh a
particular example that well known this
Debian open SSL problem that occurred
relatively recently in 2008 I guess the
Bellow 2008 um where some developer
commented out a couple lines of code in
the in the source for de Debian op SSL
and these two lines of code are actually
what we're responsible for adding
entropy from uh the measurements to the
uh the entropy pool so the effect was
that the ram number generator was just
spitting out uh uh one um a very limited
set of possible outputs and so these are
predictable to
adversaries and so in general there's
been um work showing that failures can
really occur at many different levels of
this process and perhaps this explains
in part why there's been so many
failures um and leading to things like
predictable Randomness or exposed
Randomness and as we'll see uh in the
the next bunch of slides repeated
Randomness as
well so to set a context for this uh
virtual machine uh reset vulnerability
work we can think of the uh following
type of usage scenario so you have a
home user who has wants to do more
secure browsing and so they uh turn to
uh handy companies like VMware who are
advertising that if you use Virtual
machines you can um have more secure
browsing sessions basically the idea is
the isolation guarantees of the virtual
machine manager going to ensure that you
know say if you get infected with a
virus or something the uh uh this won't
get uh Escape out from the virtual
machine and and infect the whole
system and so snapshots can actually
help facilitate this uh because uh of
the following thing which I'll just show
now so the idea is you have a home user
and and and he has his virtual machine
that he can set up uh say he's running
Windows or something inside of it say he
loads up his internet browser owser
because this is what he's going to use
this virtual machine for and so at this
point he takes a snapshot so the
snapshot basically is a copy of of the
entire state of the virtual machine
including all the you know active memory
Precision storage everything okay and so
now when he wants to do browsing
sessions he can resume from the snapshot
uh go serf to some one of his favorite
sites for getting some free software and
in case you made a poor choice of where
to visit and gets uh you know exploited
by some type of uh uh malicious you know
code
the virtual machine you know ends up
getting
compromised but uh the nice thing is he
can reset to the prior clean state of
the snapshot to remove all this malware
infection excuse me so this is uh pretty
nice it does actually provide some
really improved Security in the face of
these type of uh you know malware
attacks but there's been um a lot of
folklore regarding the fact that these
type of resets might cause security
issues in particular for example
garfinkle Rosenblum pointed out that
hypothetically of course you could be
replaying some type of security critical
State uh that was saved in the snapshot
if you use it multiple times this could
cause problems and so I'm just going to
refer to this as as a reset
vulnerability so this uh exists when
multiple uses of the same VM snapshot um
leads to some type of security
violation so even though this has been a
folklore problem no one really uh knew
or had pointed out whether these
actually exist in practice and so that
was the the first contribution this work
that we showed that uh these types of
resets could lead to random number
generation
failures so now the consider a situation
where you do your first browsing session
okay and so you actually want to go to a
secure website like your bank so what's
going to happen is you're going to use a
TLS key transport protocol and excuse
me uh kind of at a high level what
happens is the client here picks a a key
using its Rand M generator and sends
this key over to the server and that's
used to bootstrap the the secure
session okay but the problem is that the
next time you resume from the snapshot
and go to use uh TLS uh uh to browse
some other website the problem is the
same session the same uh key gets chosen
in this uh as well and sent over to the
next site and so this of course can be a
problem because this is actually all the
secret material that's needed to decrypt
a transcript of the the prior banking
session so if uh you know if this other
site was malicious this is a big problem
so this wasn't just an abstract problem
but we showed that uh by you know
checking out experimentally with Firefox
and chrome uh they actually allow this
this type of problem um in current
versions you know under a couple
different virtual machine managers VMR
server and virtual box and so underneath
the hood what What's Happening Here is
that the the browser uh generated some
Randomness that got captured in the
snapshot and used mult multiple times to
generate these session
keys so we went on to look at other
settings uh where this might be a prom
and so we want to look at the other side
of of TLS connections and look at
servers and so we looked at Apache modl
which is the most popular U server
software for for uh
TLS and here we looked at in a
particular mode where you're using the
DSA signing algorithm for authentication
of the
server and uh the we're able to show
that uh what happens is if you resume
the server twice from the same snapshot
with the Damon running um and an
adversary is able to get the first few
connections to the server after this
resumption then you can actually extract
the DSA secret key and so of course this
is bad because this uh you know allows
impersonating the server um and all
sorts of of
problems so this might yeah sorry goe so
I'm just trying to make sure I
understand the model so in your model
when you uh reset back do you assume
that the random number generator is
deterministic from now on or do you
we're not assuming anything this is
Apache software that's we downloaded
from the internet so uh I'm G sorry go
ahead well abstractly I guess I'm trying
to see are you because you're saying
there is this Randomness and so here
you're not assuming Randomness is the
problem reset or the problem bet
Randomness in this case this problem is
is Randomness being repeated with DSA
and I'll go into some more details um
the the the problem with the signing
algorithm itself is that if you this is
well known you can I I kind of worked
out with pen and paper then realized you
can just check Wikipedia for this um but
with DSA uh uh if you sign two different
messages with the same Randomness um and
you give some adory the public key the
two messages and the signatures they can
just extract the secret key and that's
just the properties of DSA it's very
fragile to uh to Randomness
abuse okay so how is this actually
coming up inside of of Apache well
easiest way way I explain maybe is a
kind of a logical timeline of events so
first uh the administrator launches this
Apache Damon inside of the virtual
machine uh at this point uh Apache
software actually Forks off a bunch of
child processes that are going to be
used to handle individual connections um
at this point the CH children processes
have their random number generators
initialized they they take uh some some
initial Randomness from from Dev random
or some other
source okay so now the dam running and
we can take a snapshot and resume later
from
it next thing is that uh you get a htps
request handled so this say the first
request that comes in and this gets
assigned to one of the children
processes so actually at this point the
Apache does something that uh is smart
or seems smart which is to update now
the sources for the Rand number gener
with with the current time um the child
process ID which is unique to the child
process and actually a portion of the
Run time stack in the process so you're
grabbing a bunch of stuff out of memory
and sticking in source and then at this
point the ram is is taken from the ram
number generator and used with the DSA
signing
algorithm so this actually seemed
problematic from the point of view of of
actually getting the an attack to work
um in particular the VM managers we
looked at um synchronized their uh the
guest time with with the internet so you
know if you're running from two
different VM snapshots but they're not
at the same time obviously ones after
the other then this would uh give you
different Randomness from the RNG
process so but when we took a closer
look and then played around with some
experiments we actually realized that
what happens uh at least with the
virtual machine managers that we looked
at was that the guest networking would
go up before synchronization would occur
and so this actually left a window of
opportunity to sneak in connection
requests by an attacker to uh try to get
two connections uh that
used excuse me um the same Randomness to
do the
signing
so so we did some experiments and this
is basically reporting on on kind of the
a very simple setup where we had um a
snapshot running off server and then we
would start resuming this uh snapshot
and then on another computer we would
have a a TLS client just try and Rush
connections or not even rush just
connect serially to the uh to the Apache
server then at some point
the guest the uh the Apache networking
would go up and a connection request
would go through and so we were
basically trying to get the first one
and then we would do this uh many times
so we would repeat
um uh um five different times I guess uh
uh doing this resuming from the snapshot
and running connections then we look for
for uh repeat Randomness across pairs of
these these trials and so yeah sorry go
I can't remember for DSA can you
actually this by casually inspecting the
signature that Randomness has been yeah
exactly what we yeah so so the
randomness is like the first component
of the signature so you can just look um
to see if you're successful yeah um and
so yeah the right column is the most
relevant uh uh thing and you know so
virtual box which had very consistent
timing so basically the amount of time
from when snapshot would go up to when
networking would go up was always the
same in each of these then you get the
same Randomness out uh and VMware was a
little bit less so but still uh still
had problems
so
um this just kind of brings up some
questions about what do we do with you
know about random and virtual
virtualized world what uh what type of
problems are going on here so we had
this this initial issue with the
browsers this is a pro a problem that
you know kind of solely was happening in
the application space that Firefox or
Chrome was caching Randomness that it
was getting and this was getting
captured in a
snapshot this issue with Apache which is
something some type of combination of
problems right it was uh you know it was
trying to reset its Rand number
generator with new sources but those
sources at least the ones that were
taken after the snapshot uh when when a
child or when a c came into a child
weren't sufficiently different between
runs so you didn't have enough
differentiation you still had a high
probability of of of getting the same
Randomness out um and then you know
there's there's actually further
problems that we didn't actually
completely explore yet so in the cases
you look at there's an RNG that's in
proc that is it's linked into the binary
the executable itself it's not calling a
system call I mean they you said that in
both apache's case and and in Chrome
it's calling through it's getting random
out of Dev random or de random or
whatever back up but there's an entropy
pool in the application itself sure so
this is this is a you know maybe a bit
misleading I'm not trying to say the RNG
process here what I'm what I'm showing
is necessarily the the operating systems
um Rand number generator um now if
Apache had actually gone to Dev random
afterwards then the uh it's not clear
whether they would have gotten good
Randomness or not and this actually what
was my next point was going to be but
you're right the the fact is a lot of
applications kind of have their own Ram
number generators internally in in in
their in their process and they're kind
of doing their own thing which is much
more of the situation I guess with
Firefox is very clear they're kind of
you know maybe they had initially gone a
good thing but then after uh good good
Randomness from dead random but after
that they're just doing their own thing
in process space for for a variety of
reasons um but the fact is even if they
were always going into the operating
system uh random number generator like
Dev random uh Dev random gets rolled
back during these resets as well and so
while we didn't we haven't explored it
fully um it's hypothetically the case
that you might have not enough uh um
difference in the sources going into Dev
random in between a snapshot resumption
and when you need Randomness from Dev
random to cause differentiation snapshot
basically to roll the under pool forward
I'm sorry I say that unless you take
steps when you make the snapshot right
so if you modify how the the operating
system deals with snapshots that'd be
good but but right now currently at
least in some uh virtual machine manager
situation they don't actually know that
there's a snapshot being taken at all so
the operating system is ignorant of when
snapshots
occur and of course there's this other
uh uh concern with random number
generators and virtualized settings that
that uh you know maybe the source events
aren't even as good uh for software
based Ram number generators as you uh
would would hope for um and again this
is kind of a lurking issue that we
didn't really explore uh fully either so
so often get asked if there's just you
know aren't there easy fixes to this
right can't we just uh build a good
virtual machine managing uh a good
hypervisor based RNG so backup Dev
random with something the hypervisor uh
knows about maybe we could use something
like the Next Generation Intel chips
that have a ram number generation
instruction uh built in so you can just
call the uh you know one instruction get
Randomness from the chip so this would
be you know helpful to have such a solid
design but unfortunately it's not going
to fix some of these problems right
first it's it's not going to fix
problems that occur in the this in the
application layer um because even if you
have a good operating system/ hypervisor
based RNG uh if the application is
cashing things you're still toasted now
it should help potentially fix these
other types of problems like with Dev
random being bad or if Apache had had
had been configured to go to the
operating system uh on every connection
uh request and it you know it should fix
this but uh it's unclear um how to
exactly design this it's a nice
interesting question and and furthermore
it's not fix all the problems
unfortunately
yeah here between the time when
the even if you use an RNG instruction
you pull it pull the randomness then get
then get snapshot right so so yeah I've
kind of glossed over that so there there
is this kind of race condition like
element to this uh you know actually
initial versions of this paper we talked
about like time of sampling to time of
use problems right um
because you can never really achieve a
aity at least in theory with snapshots
if they can happen in arbitrary
instruction steps then yeah you're
absolutely right um so hypothetically
yeah you're never going to be able to
solve this problem but I think from a
practical point of view it's it's less
likely and so it's not a sure solution
but we should we should we should uh if
we because like so for example if you if
you think about when TLS connection
requests come in and if you do the
sampling then it's much less it's not
the fact that you're going to have a TLS
connection that that uh was initialized
before a snapshot was taken and
continued afterwards in in the type of
application scenarios I'm envisioning
right now now in the future that may not
be true that you could keep a TLS
connection going you know uh through
some type of snapshot or replication of
a VM um but uh yeah it's it's I mean
basically this slide is not pointing out
Solutions it's pointing out that this is
a can of worms that needs to be
investigated uh much further I think um
for a variety of
reasons so if there aren any more more
questions I'm going to kind of now take
a a sharp right turn maybe in some sense
and and try and treat this this another
question that um our this previous work
kind of raises which is why is our
cryptographic primitive so why are
cryptographic Primitives so ridiculously
fragile to this repeated Randomness use
yeah I'm just I'm just curious I guess a
folklore um solution uh would be
essentially again is this reset attacks
would be more or less that you store a
key let's say for like random function
or something like that and whenever you
know you need fresh Randomness you just
take the current state of your
applications like everything that happen
so far and essentially I mean maybe more
effici app to the random function so
essentially so even with reset attack
you reset attack now you do something
different something you apply prf and
it's kind of right for the virion number
of virtu machine no but you said
everything is the same but then presum
if you do something else like a yeah so
so you're you're foreshadowing some of
the rest of this talk right I mean that
at the end of the day what we're going
to say is look we should be changing The
cryptographic Primitives so that that
they handle this this this failure case
for the randomness and so we'll build
into the crypto Primitives what's going
on yeah but the folklore solution is
very close to what we were suggesting uh
for practical Solutions yeah justess the
point I think also architecturally it's
it's it's a good design principle to do
it in the cograph not
not cuz sometimes you will want to have
Randomness that you want to repeat when
you don't don't want to always Force
fresh Rand on the application right
because for debugging all kinds of
reasons for you know to prove things on
the code you really want to be able to
REO from the original Rand right yeah I
think in general we're trying to stress
this idea that if you if you make
algorithmic changes to the the crypto
oper we can reason about them we can we
can clarify what you're getting out of
the changes in terms of the various
Randomness failure models and so that's
what the rest of this talk is be about
so um I just wanted to stress for in
case it wasn't apparent that you know
the type talk talked about some of the
other attacks on RAM number generation
failures um aren't abusing bad Ramis
during like Long Live key generation
right so the DSA key was generated with
with good Randomness and it was fine and
really these this is just uh a problem
with the routine operations and the
randomness needed for things like
signing or key exchange or public key
encryption Okay so so uh you know this
is not just a problem with DSA um or or
uh or the key exchange key transport
mechanism but you know lots of
cryptographic algorithms have problems
right as soon as you take away the uh
the good Randomness uh and that's you
know in part because we've been building
cryptographic Primitives under the
assumption that we have good Randomness
around it and it's it's plentiful and
maybe kind of more philosophically even
that uh you know for many of our
standard um security goals you know you
need good Randomness to achieve them and
and provably so and and we'll see an
example of this in a
minute so anyway the idea is uh we want
to you know fix this right now we have
uh problems when Randomness gets bad so
you these like repetition Randomness the
VM resets you have even situations where
you have predictable Randomness like the
Debian uh situation and so we're saying
okay let's try and fix this and and at
least try and make our routine
cryptographic operations the ones that
use Randomness to do things like signing
key exchange to be as secure as possible
in the face of bad randomness and
unfortunately we're
yeah bad Randomness is is is different
than repeated Randomness yeah I'm being
rather loose with my terminology here
but um uh when I say bad I really mean
any lower quality than perfectly uniform
um and
then
um uh repeating PR I'll try and clarify
for particular things I'm not going to
go into too much detail uh and the
models and stuff anyway but yeah bad
really means anything except except good
which and good is defined as something
that's fresh and uniform and private and
never
exposed and so the idea is that okay we
we may not actually be able to achieve
our strongest Notions of security uh
without good Randomness but that's okay
we won't just give up and we'll try to
uh Define uh Notions and and meet them
that still provide some meaningful level
of security should the randomness be not
as good as we were hoping for okay so
I'll do I'll go through an example of
this with uh public key encryption which
is kind of something easy to deal with
and has very interesting um um
definitional issues actually when it
comes to uh looking at uh models with
degraded Randomness so just to drive the
point home we have a very simple um
public encryption scheme right like
using hybrid encryption with um in this
case counter mode encryption and of
course this is well known to be um
secure under semantic Securities indd
CPA um but uh you know when the
randomness is bad for uh repeat
Randomness in this case you can learn
quite a bit about messages just from two
Cipher text right so if you use the same
randoms twice you end up using uh the
same as applic uh application um and you
get the same pad and okay you can learn
the exor of two messages for example if
the randomness is totally predictable um
of course you can just recover the
message immediately right uh where here
yeah R is the set of of potential uh
Randomness values okay so this is no
good so what what's going on okay of
course
uh uh you know this is clear to
everybody to most people but go through
it quickly anyway so we have our our our
traditional publicy encryption notion
which is semantic security and um uh so
what happens here well you have a
challenging environment in an adverse
area which is some arbitrary program so
the the challenging Environ picks a
random bit B and uh the adversary gets
to challenge two different messages and
what happens now is that the environment
is going to sample R uniformly at random
and and encrypt uh the one of the two
messages based on this challenge bit um
under the public key and give back the
cipher text and now the adversary tries
to guess the bit and and wins so um this
uh so I said this previous scheme of
course is is secure uh under this notion
um so what's the catch of course the
catch is that the in the our model we we
built in the assumption that the ramus
is always good okay and so we'd like to
remove this assumption and or we're
going to have to remove this assumption
in a model that's going to provide uh
something for us to analyze um public
encryp when the ram is no
good so we uh in this paper at agac
Crypt uh last year a variety of of great
co-authors um we presented this idea of
chosen distribution ATT tax and so it
actually extends on quite a bit of of
previous work in in the context of
deterministic public key encryption
there's some natural parallels uh which
are in turn based on some some previous
work on entropic security and let me
just give you uh a sense of what the the
definition is is so again we have a
challenging environment in an adversary
and again we're going to choose a random
bit
B and now at this point instead of
querying two different messages the
adversary is going to query uh an
algorithm basically uh or what we call a
source and from this we run it with some
fresh private coins and it outputs uh
some Randomness R and then two messages
m0 and M1 okay so now the coins that are
used to run this algorithm uh are hidden
from the adversary but the adversary
gets to pick how the uh uh distribution
of of R and not M1 um is is defined and
so at this point we encrypt one of the
two messages under the randomness that
was output by this algorithm and return
the cipher text in the public key to the
adversary and he gets to again try and
guess uh the
bit okay so we're not done yet there's a
lot of other stuff uh one very important
issue is that this we can't provide
security for arbitrary um s uh arbitrary
M so in particular we need some typee of
unpredictability of the messages
Randomness otherwise uh it's trivial for
the adversary to win so we require that
uh this m must have high Min entropy so
that the outputs uh for any uh so each
pair of outputs rm0 and rm1 are
unpredictable from the adversary
Viewpoint the connection between Big M
and to the two little M Big M and uh so
Big M is an algorithm and it and it gets
provided fresh coins and the output is
this this uh Triple R m0 and M1 so you
can think of M as as um as a
distribution on messages and and
Randomness that the adversary gets to
pick okay and it's going to get some fed
some private coins and it outputs uh
what ends up becoming the the message
and Randomness that are used with the
public key for the for the challenge
that of T and PKA is derived from uh I'm
sorry uh yeah I didn't show PKA is
chosen uh correctly by the environment
so it runs the the key generation
algorithm of the encryption scheme and
outputs a public key secret key pair uh
doesn't output it it generates them and
and uses the public key and then
provides the public key to the adversary
after the
challenge CR right uh does yes does not
does not c yeah I mean unless C leaks it
in which case youd have problems so
importantly he doesn't see PK he doesn't
see PK yeah so this is very yeah there's
a lot of subtleties to this definition
and in fact I only showed you a very
rudimentary kind of simplification of it
um so one thing is that actually we have
to Define an M that doesn't output just
three values but actually outputs three
vectors of values and the reason we have
to do that is that because in this
setting for uh the most liberal uh
notion of of Min entropy um single
message security doesn't imply multi
security as it does in the in the
randomized encryption case so it's a bit
technical but the idea is yeah you need
to uh output vectors as well so you get
back a vector of Cipher
Tex uh this then gives rise to another
problem which is that um the uh which is
what we call equality pattern uh
restrictions so the fact is if you're
outputting a vector the just the um
equality of R message Randomness pairs
is going to be represented in the cipher
text that get output because the cipher
text will be equal so the pattern of
equalities inside the cipher text could
leak information uh trivially and this
doesn't really say much uh in terms of
security so we basically have to have
some restrictions saying that the uh
adversary pix and M that doesn't take
advantage of this fact so for example we
could uh assume that uh or we could Ru
require that M outputs uh just unique
pairs of R and M values in the vector so
all the cipher Texs end up being
unique um there's uh we also actually
defined an Adaptive variant so um that
you can actually query multiple times
these these messages that uh output
vectors and this actually has some very
interesting ramifications because of
what I'll talk about a sec which is the
public key issue um that if you can
query multiple times this is not
equivalent to just querying once with a
vector because uh the encryption scheme
could leak some information about the
public key which is problematic in this
case if you can Define message
distributions as a function of the
public
key um and so as you kind of pointed out
if if the uh uh adversary gets to Define
message uh these uh these M Samplers as
a defin as a function of the public key
then uh he can trivially win and I won't
go into details but it's kind of a
simple thing to to a simple exercise and
uh so for that reason uh at least uh
this this definition does not imply indd
CPA our our traditional notion which is
uh unfortunate but seems
inherent okay so uh so in particularly
in light of that last fact that uh this
new definition is not um stronger than
indd CPA when we target building what
we're calling hedge public encryption
schemes we're going to Target both goals
at the same time so we want to have
something that uh is in dcpa Secure when
Randomness is good in the traditional
sense and now additionally um is CDA
secure and this provides um uh security
for a variety of of random failure
models and I have a little parenthetical
comment here that uh there was some work
uh by by one of our co-authors Scott but
in a separate paper showing an
enhancement dcpa that kinds the the very
particular type of of Randomness failure
which is resets um and there you can do
a little bit better than with CDA
definition but I don't want to go into
the the details of it um you ask me
about
later so uh in in this paper we explored
a bunch of different constructions
there's kind of some straightforward
ways to go from or some straight forward
approaches to go from determinist
encryption to to hedged encryption so
for examp yeah yeah please what is CDA
oh I'm sorry CDA is this uh chosen
distribution attack security yeah sorry
I should have thrown around acronyms I'm
familiar with but no one else is um yeah
so this is the new definition that we
want to
achieve U okay so we can
uh there's like two natural approaches
if you have deterministic encryption
scheme which is one that doesn't use
Randomness to provide uh uh a public
encryption scheme and you have
randomized encryption scheme there's uh
you know two natural approaches based on
composition now only one of these is is
secure as it turns out uh under our
definition and so um don't don't do this
one I guess um there's another uh
natural approach just using a ter
encryption scheme of special type of one
one that ends up being Universal l trap
door function you can kind of do an even
simpler thing which is just padding out
the message with sufficient Randomness
uh and then you can show that this
actually gives you a hedge secure
scheme
um we went on to to look at just doing a
now a general framework so talking about
public encryption we treated that case
and then this uh ndss paper we we wanted
to say okay well yeah please go ahead so
does this capture also this repeated run
this so um
so not entirely so the problem is the
public key Independence issue again so
you can you can uh you can model some
forms of repeat Randomness like your
message distribution Vector could output
two could output vectors that have the
same Randomness in each one but but
uniform um and so it captures that but
that's only for public key independent
distributions the definition of of yck
uh actually just takes icpa enhances it
and shows that you can you can give the
adversary additional uh Power to reset
to get encryptions under the same
Randomness multiple times and you can
actually achieve uh something that's uh
does not have just public key
independent distributions so um so it is
also orthogonal to to the the CDA
definition but is stronger than indd
CPA
yeah great uh so okay so we had this
idea so let's we can just Define uh kind
of a general framework for uh hedging
you know arbitrary routine cryptographic
operations this really goes back to the
kind of the folklore idea that um y geni
alluded to earlier then we take we have
some operation that has some input some
keys some Randomness what we're going to
do is just run all this through a
hedging function to derive new effective
Randomness for use with the uh
underlying routine
operation um and this uh has a number of
of nice properties for for practical
crypto one it doesn't impact
functionality so you can immediately
deploy it um so for example on TLS you
can you know hedge one side of a
connection the other side doesn't need
no um and or or vice versa or both which
would be even
better um so for for and you know in the
paper we suggested that you there's a
variety of ways you could uh implement
the hedging function that you have to be
a little bit careful um we suggested
using hmac is a sufficiently strong hash
function and the reason is that it has
two at least two nice properties one is
that when the key is good when this
Randomness is good you get a pseudo
random
function and even if the key is bad then
at least you get the the idea that hemac
behaves like an ideal hash function and
and gives you uh something that is you
know good enough to be model as a random
Oracle in our
proofs so with public encryption we can
do this uh and then we get this kind of
uh ladder of of of security uh that we
get so under good Randomness you know if
we have our traditional ncpa notion well
this meets it and we can get by with a
relatively mild assumption on the Hedge
function and then when the ram is
repeated we have to strengthen our
assumption a little bit but then we meet
this repeated goal and then for entirely
uh so for example like for the case
parus we get um uh we can still meet
this but now we have to make uh the
random Oracle assumption on on the
hedging
function so but the point we want to
emphasize that you know by doing this
you're not degrading really the the
security guarantee you got in the
original case we're not we're not doing
any worse than we did before at the very
least okay so you can do this with other
primitiv so for example signing problem
with the DSA attacks that we had before
uh you can do the same type of thing and
here you even uh you get yeah similar
type of uh
situation so just to drive it home of
course if if hedging already been
implemented these attacks you know
wouldn't have worked at least there
would have been no uh catastrophic
failure of these these uh um protocols
and so you know the takeaway is that
really hedging of course is not going to
replace our need for good Ram number
generators but it's going to give us
some nice defense and properties built
into our Cog graphic Primitives that we
can reason about should we have failures
which seem to unfortunately happen all
too
often uh we went ahead and implemented
hedging in op SSL um and you know ran
some numbers uh and stuff it doesn't
cost much I guess the takeaway you know
no one's going to notice if you have
hedging running more numbers and stuff
okay so um uh anyway yeah just to wrap
up okay so we saw two things right VM
reset vulnerabilities and hedge
cryptography um
VM reset abilities right we're going to
have lots of soft we have lots of
software out there already that was
designed for a world in which you know
virtual machines didn't really exist or
or at least I should say weren't being
used uh and this Legacy software isn't
designed with things like resets in mind
and um so when you have uh this new kind
of uh almost computation model going on
in the background that you know things
are getting reset uh applications are
going to break and I think the at least
people have been thinking very carefully
about how to make functionality
preserved in this type of new world for
virtual virtualization but when it comes
to security people of course aren't
thinking about this as much and the
concern is that we have these type of
vulnerabilities with Le the Rand number
generators and there might be a lot of
other problems lurking out there uh and
so my sense is that this is a big can of
worms that we're going to have to deal
with on the other side of the fence we
have the the Hedge crypto okay let's
let's uh try to make our cryptography
behave Less embarrassingly in in the
face of bad randoms um for practical
crypto can be very fast and simple um
you know of course the catch is that you
end up with complicate looking
definitions sometimes and maybe uh
relatively complex analyses but uh
that's okay give cryptographers
something to do um and uh yeah and so
the idea is to provide good defense and
depth or or graceful de degradation of
of of security in the face of uh bad
Ramis failures and of course there's
this one uh kind of open thing to do is
to sit back at least for the case of ram
number generators and look back at how
we should be designing these in of
resets so uh I'll leave it there and
take any questions more questions I
should
say so this this notion of hedging can
be done
essentially kind of that's right
yeah see I
mean you can do it to anyone but you
should you should check what you're
doing and so there seems like in general
it seems like it should be um totally
fine but uh we didn't do we don't have
some type of argument saying that no
matter what security property you're
trying to achieve hedging will will pres
you know not sacrifice it so and my
sense is actually you could find counter
examples that for some cryptographic
printers if you do hedging maybe you've
done things that you don't like you can
think about things like non-committing
encryption or something or sorry wait
non-committing encryption committing
yeah non-committing encryption would be
potentially compromised because you're
you're running the randomness through
this thing um so you can apply it
anywhere but probably should have people
look at each example yeah go ahead in
the 60s 7s ' 80s as '90s there was a
favorite of papers on how to take IBM's
horrible random number generator and
make it do something decent have you
check whether there any good ideas to
spe from there or it not typological uh
I have not um so what was bad with the
IBM one I can explain to you okay yeah I
mean there's there's random number
generators seem to be something that we
haven't gotten right by any stretch of
the imagination uh over here
so uh yeah so thing I'm just curious how
far it goes because I'm curious how far
this uh you know hedging goes because
conceivably I guess I don't know how
slow it would be but you can always like
do stuff that you have some Curren SE
and whenever some new data comes in just
apply keep applying mer Dam and when you
reset and the new data comes in you will
go possibly in a different direction so
essentially it's like I'm suggesting
implementing some kind of interative prf
like some kind
so you're basically saying you maintain
some State maintain some fresh State U
where you know every next Whenever there
is some new data which is you know
particular to your application you will
update the state there so I think you're
right in the sense that if as long as
you're careful to stick all the same
type of inputs that we're sticking into
the hedging here into the stateful thing
you're good but I feel like stateful is
just going to make things more
complicated to deal with this way I'm
saying I mean it seems It's not CU
you're getting any efficiency speed up
there either right what what's the no
I'm just saying it's uh no it's not
efficiency it's essentially it seems
like if you want to get as bulletproof
thing in the presence of reset attacks
um that's the way to go when you say
application kind of specific Randomness
presumably the problem will be that when
the attack like a different message you
reuse the same Randomness here no the
moment you change the message the
randomness will also you know because in
you're not saying that we have bad Rand
you have you say you have good randoms
but due to reset it might repeat when
every new stuff comes in new message
comes in you use new random for the
signing so kind of maybe maybe build it
almost to the system level kind of thing
that but have a there is some state of
application it's require so the yeah so
so yes you could uh rebuild your Rand
generation process inside applications
just have a prf key lying there and then
they they hash they run it over things
but the question is you have to be
careful about what things you stick into
it right um
um because there could be Corner cases I
don't have great examples I have some
like antidotes that you know if you put
too much stuff into it adversarially
controlled things you might be affecting
other security properties elsewhere so
if you kind of take it out of the crypto
primitive uh it's harder to do the
analysis um if if system designers kind
of throw things in so one of the things
is if we do hedging in the Primitive we
can kind of like just do it and then not
people don't have to be the wiser right
and we can do the analysis uh own I mean
I'm actually suggesting something maybe
maybe on The Parting system level which
has both features so essentially your
application whenever you design a
process you have a option to specify you
know periodically the next batch of
application specific data which you want
to be used to mix Randomness so maybe so
I me you essentially have that type of
API now with Rand M generators right you
can have an application say here to the
open SSL Rand M generator here here's a
bunch of application specific stuff that
I want you to mix into the pool but I
mean but it's not clear people do this
uh and it's not clear it's always the
right thing to do necessarily I mean you
have to be careful that's all I'm saying
it could be okay um whereas the hedging
thing uh you know it's simple because we
can look at it in the context of the
cryptographic algorithm and that's
that's the the takeaway benefit I think
yeah so assume that you had a hardware
RNG yes I'm assuming that yes and
because now I'm assuming well I because
I'm thinking about this in the windows
context right where you're looking at VM
snapshots but it's actually not that
much different than saying I've got a
bunch of identical machines that I'm
going to power on equivalently in a data
center right okay independent of the VM
sort of issue the VM is just about push
the state out can I the state so um
we've certainly noticed issues with enty
across machines one of the ways we fix
that is you put TPMS in and they scrape
the TPMS early and often right that give
you some hard cons so presumbly now you
guys are going to move to the you use
Intel chips you just can use the ARB
restruction or if that's there depends
on I we'll take advantage of anything we
have we have a model where will take
entropy from a variety of part sources
so you know more marer um if if I and
then there's a case that you didn't
explicitly highlight but I think it's
related which is that generally when you
power down and rebooting machine there
is a save of the pool right right and
then that's that's similar to a snapshot
you have to do some protection there to
effectively roll the pull forward uh
it's not it's not exactly the same as
duplicating snapshot right duplicating
because you're still moving forward
always the time move it forward yeah
when you do a VM fot up you either mix
in from your Hardware at that point in
time when you bring the snapshot back or
if you know that when you save the
snapshot out you roll the pool right
right you know there's ways that you
could defend against this at the OS
level that's true if your application is
playing ball right the problem is that
the application needs to make sure it's
not uh so these are cases where the
application or I'm assuming that the OS
provides a system RNG right so I think
we would go a long ways if we had a nice
and and like you know cryptographically
Sanctified or whatever approach to doing
um the V the remember from the operating
system the vmm support right so even if
you have all that which I agree that's
going to go a long ways to helping the
situation you still need the
applications to use it correctly just
you know the same problem we've always
had with random number Jers applications
need to use it correctly that it's that
the apps are putting their own rngs into
their apps as opposed to calling the
system certified one well I don't know I
mean the thing is when I and I'm not
positive with the design rationalis
between behind like uh I'm not positive
with design rationalis but my suspicion
is like for things like Firefox you know
they they grab ramus at at boot up time
because it's it's inefficient to grab
Rams otherwise maybe this goes away if
you have an Intel instruction that's
very quick to give you Randomness um but
anyway they want to do this for
efficiency so they cash it before the
next connection request goes out because
they want to optim that's like on the
critical path right so they thought they
could take random number generation out
of the critical path what we're saying
with snapshots of the application layer
you need to put it back in the CR
critical path you know for for this type
of thing like like uh browser TLS
request um so but but you're 100% right
like we need we need to to get good Ram
number generators built into the
operating system and the virtual uh and
the vmm and have Hardware backup uh
Hardware sources and and then it's just
a matter of making sure applications are
doing the right thing which I think
includes kind of updating cryptographic
best practices about saying you know you
need you can't do random number
generation grabbing like you know four
days ago and then use it later I mean
you need to really kind of put it in the
critical path thing how much of this
problem is because the applications you
looked at are effectively implementing
their own rngs and Brock as opposed to
and therefore they're caching they're
pulling State out of the system Dev
random or Dev e random right they P that
up and they're then doing their own rngs
as a second it's an open question it's
an open question so you're right I think
the attacks as is would not work if you
hit de Dev random every time even
without a good vmm backed up Dev random
um but it it's not clear you it's not
clear you're secure still I mean it may
be that you still have some probability
of having repetition because it depends
on what the sources are going to Dev
random at that point now if you replace
Dev random with something that's vmm
backed up and you're hitting Dev random
right before the application uses the
randomus then you're probably okay
except for this kind of nagling theor
radical issue that there's it's not
Atomic right it's not that the app is
doing its own RNG it's that the app
pulled some Randomness a little before
no technically so so these are some of
them do they have their own RNG like in
logic inside the application and and
some of them go to Dev random sometimes
to refresh it let's just I'm that's
exactly I'm saying hypothetically if
they always went to Dev random it would
be better but I'm saying that wouldn't
fix uh even if you gap between the two
no but look look at what happens on
Windows okay as a as a counter to this
right M so you call into the SSL stack
that's a common system sort of thing
that calls down into into the RNG inside
of the cap right and in fact there's a
fan out down there and I've actually got
eight of them for performance reason
that kind of R Rob and I've got a state
inside there there's a that state so
you've got rngs that are a system
function right you have to worry about
whether or not that gets persistent okay
and where and where when you spin those
up when you bring the OS up where do
they pull entropy from so the question
is where's the entropy pool that your
system I mean it's matter of you've got
an RNG there's an entry pull backing it
who pulls entropy from that it's not
just who but when right is the question
yeah and and then if you snapshot it do
you detect that properly and do you
effectively mix something else into it
so that you avoid the
duplication but once the randomness has
been cooled from cool to the app right
there's this time there's this gap
between sure and so the question becomes
that is the app pulling Randomness from
the pool right before it's being used or
holding it on the and is it deriving any
further from it right right yeah so I
mean what he's saying is sometimes they
pull it from from the uh from the
operating system and then they use that
as like a prf key same I mean but I mean
either way it doesn't matter I
so I mean it's a there's kind of
problems at a lot of different levels
and I maybe I didn't do the best job of
of clarifying that there's like problem
a b and c I mean there's like a bunch of
problems mixed together here um but uh
in any case we need to figure out how to
do good random number generation vmm
settings and then we need to educate
application design about uh proper use
in the case in the in the context of
resets um and actually doing that it's
easy easy to say that but doing it is
probably a lot hard yeah sry well I
guess maybe shouldn't take too much time
but I'm just saying my no my suggestion
very quickly is instead of just calling
whenever you need random you just call
that random with no inputs just call def
random with an optional application
specific input and then the operating so
that the user doesn't have to know about
prfs or something says you know what
maybe there is some said I'll just call
def random this an optional users speci
my input and the operating system
guarantees that if the seat was good
even if it's repeated it will
incorporate my that's all I'm suggesting
that should if the if the seed was good
then guarantee so I'm the user the only
extra interface I want instead of just
calling def random and using Randomness
myself so I need I might need to know
about the random functions or something
I just call def random with an optional
argument which is something user
specific maybe a message to be signed or
whatever and then I'm guaranteed that
the I get is going to incorporate my
optional input so I mean that doesn't so
that that might be one solution but that
I mean that doesn't change the three
things I said you need to do right and
what you're suggesting there requires
application changes right so no
application no no the application needs
to do this right because you change the
API but that's AAL change right yeah so
you have to change all the applications
used at random right so which which may
not be an optional argument right so if
it's you know take an existing
application if a you know you compile
but if we want security then you can't I
mean you have to make sure it's not OP
no but I'm just saying the operating
system change I'm surprised why theom
doesn't take user specify argument and
then it will I think there's a host of
reasons but you have to ask someone to
sign the
API yeah I think I'm way over on time so
right thank you yeah let's than the
speaker thank you all right um uh next
speaker is Kristoff P speaking on
Subspace lwe Kristoff is from
CWF okay uh can you hear
me so I will speak about something which
actually honestly has nothing to do with
the cloud but uh I will talk about it
anyway so it's about the learning with
errors problem so here is a short
outline of the talk I will first Define
the learning with errors problem and the
less General learning parities with
noise problem then I will show you in
this is a non-adaptive hardness
assumption uh then I will show you an
Adaptive assumption which just has the
term Subspace in front of it and
actually prove give a short proof that
those two assumptions are equivalent the
original one and this Adaptive One and
then I'll show some cool cool
application of this of this new
assumption okay so what is the learning
parities with noise problem this is a
problem that comes has a long history it
has been looked at by people from
learning theory and so on and it's
defined very simply so you have like
some person who has access to a blackbox
this
blackbox this blackbox has some uh
random bit string of length n inside it
and some parameter between zero and one
half and then the the person can just
ask give me a sample and what this box
does is it samples a uni from random bit
string of length n it samples an error
which with beri distribution with
parameter to this means this is a random
variable which is zero with
probability uh sorry this is a random
variable which is one with probability
to and the just bias toward zero and
then what this box outputs is yeah this
random R and the inner product so
bitwise uh bitwise uh multiplic bitwise
multiplication with r and the secret S
Plus added this little bit of noise to
it and yeah we will say that so this
learning parties with noise problem is
hard so parameterized by this length of
the secret end the number of maybe
samples that the adversary does this par
noise parameter to you say It's s
Epsilon hard if at the advantage of any
adversary of outputting actually the
secret is upper bounded by Epsilon so
this is the computational version of the
LPN problem you can also Define a
decisional version so in this case we
have an adversary who has either access
to the box that I just described or to a
box which actually does adds un from
random error to this thing so actually
the entire string is uniformly random
and then we say okay this problem is
hard if uh the adversary has at most
Advantage Epsilon in distinguish these
two cases and in fact this decisional
and computational version have been
shown to be a polinomial equivalent okay
that's the learning parties with noise
problem it has been generalized by reg
f05 to a problem that is called learning
with errors again we have like a secret
but it's now not a bit string but like a
string of elements in setq and we uh
have not just the error parameter but
like some distri error
distribution G which outputs uh so this
this is a distribution over elements in
uh in zq what is used actually in this
assumption is something that is called a
discrete gaussian so it's like an nrow
distribution it looks like a gausian and
this that's like small variance like I
think square root of Q or something
is what you usually use okay the distrib
uh the game is the same we sample a
random R in zq uh we sample error
according to this distribution and the
other adversary can ask for arbitrary
many samples and again we say that this
problem is hard if you cannot
distinguish and again the decisional
version is you cannot distinguish this
distribution here from uniform from a
box that just gives uniform random
stuff okay why is what is known about
this problem so as I said before the
decisional and computational versions
are the same and from now on I will
always talk when I talk about lpnl LW I
will always talk about the decisional
version so the stronger version where
you ask to distinguish random from uh
from the
samples uh the learning parities with
noise yes
not are the equivalent for any mod or is
it um so
as so so the LPN is the mod is to and I
think I don't really know what regf
shows Chris knows that very better Prime
polom Q or Q
KSS what's
KSS uh that's I took this from reg's
overview on learning with errors this is
let's see um I think
kalai and this some that's so reg
attributes it to uh to this
paper okay maybe it's a type of my side
okay I look it up
smooth okay so there are okay it's it's
equivalent for appropriate choices
of soor
yeah okay um so in the like a cool so
okay so the LPN problem is known to be
equivalent to decoding random linear
codes this is average case hardness
assumption and the what's cool about the
lwe assumption is so when this R
distribution is something called a
discrete gaan this problem has been
shown by regf to be as hard as worst
case latis problem so this is
a I mean the first works for
every
okay so and these problems lwe and the
less General LPN problem have been used
in cryptography a lot so LW has been
used so for one thing because it has
this extremely cool uh hardness
guarantee and for another thing it has
turned out to be extremely versatile for
crypto so so Chris and vot and other
people have built pretty much any
primitive you can think of from lwe like
yeah public encryption IB hype and I
know what signatures and so on the LPN
problem is less versatile so it's uh so
there is something like it's less
versatile for for doing crypto but it it
still has found usages because it's
extremely efficient because we just
basically do bit bitwise taking in a
products that's extremely fast so you
might have heard about this
authentication protocols due to hoer and
Plum I will come to this
later okay so so I so this lwe problem
is uh is a non-interactive hardness
assumption you just get samples you
distinguish okay now let me Define a new
hardness assumption that I would call
Subspace LW which is now an Adaptive
hardness assumption so now the adversary
actually can interact with this box the
Box again is parameterized so has some
secret of length m inste q moreover it's
parameterized again Arrow distribution G
and moreover some parameter n which has
Which is less than than M I will come in
a minute to what this this m has to do
what the adversary Now can do is he can
ask a query to this box not just give me
the next example but actually the
adversary can choose two uh two uh Pro
two aine projections VR and
vs uh so technically this is the VR is
for example given by m * m Matrix XR so
this is to to you know to to the linear
projection and these are fine so you can
have this little XR to to add something
to it same for fs and what the adversary
gets back is now the following as before
the the Box samples random R the error
distribution G but it gives back so this
random R and the inner product not of A
and S Plus the error as before but like
it first uses V to Project R to whatever
VR defined IT projects s to whatever vs
defined and then it takes the inner
product of this uh this two projected
values okay
um what is this oh yeah okay this is the
definition of the find things okay so
basically we can Define like a hardness
assumption so okay look this this uh
this problem this mntc sub LW problem is
is hard if uh if no adversary can
distinguish this and I should say
something more okay yeah what can you
repeat again what it is that the
adversary chooses yeah I forgot to say
something the adversary chooses this
matrices XR big XR small XR big XS small
XS which Define projections of R and S
and there is one constraint to this
Choice he cannot choose this arbitrary
because if he can do this this is
obviously trivial this problem one one
second because I the other you could
just protect on the first coordinate of
s ask many samples with the little error
would you could cancel it out you would
learn it so I put an additional
constraint and this constraint is that
this projectors VR and vs overlapping a
sufficiently project in overlapping a
sufficiently large Subspace and I
require that this Subspace is at has
Dimension at least n which formally
means the rank of XR and Xs has to be at
least n but otherwise the adversary can
do what he want so for example I will
show you natural example what Xs and XR
can be for example he can just take a
subset of size n of the of of the of the
element or fix all of the bits of R
except n positions yes we know so XR and
Xs let's assume for a minute little XR
little XS are zero yeah that's okay
right and big XR and Xs are public
or so this is the input to the Box the
adversary adaptively chooses this as
inputs he chooses this as inputs asks
gets stuff back chooses adaptively new
XS XR asks the Box gets a new sample
back and so
on all of them so somehow you shouldn't
rest restrict so so there restriction is
only on each pair yeah of each P
independently when it chooses this two x
XXR they have to overlap in a sufficient
L
sub okay okay but the noise is is is
chosen prandom at each time the noise is
as before the noise is exactly as in the
original LW yeah with each with each
exactly it's not the same noise it's not
the same noise no it's like the LW have
so that case the product of and PS ofs
is basically the in product of right I
mean in which case uh so the prodct you
get the X you get the xrt
XX when what I see so so when XR and Xs
are identi of identity matrices and XR
XS are zero you back to the standard
uh okay all right so let me say a few
things so to clarify this it's one one
thing is completely trivial so uh if
this this this adaptive thing is hard
then this immediately implies that the
standard LV so this is the trivial
Direction and this is very easy to see
why because okay assume
I I assume I have I have access to this
MN Subspace LW Oracle then I can and if
have an adversary who who breaks breaks
this heartness assumption to Advantage
Epsilon then I make you an uh adversary
against the standard lve assumption
which uses secrets of length n which is
the dimension of the subset that that I
have to project into in a very simple
way I just choose the inputs I always
choose the same inputs to this to this
adap to my Subspace LW or this input is
simply this XR and Xs are zero and the
projection that I use is I just use the
identity Matrix in the first uh nend
diagonal entries and the rest is zero
what happens okay what happens is that I
get the inner products of this form but
look this x r * R this just deletes out
everything of R except the first end
positions and this deletes everything
out except the first uh first end
position so what you get is basically
the product of like a prefix of s with
so if exactly the same you have exactly
the same distribution as with the normal
LW assumption that uses as a secret
substring of of S which just contains
the first El so this direction is
Trivial if the Subspace is hard the so
if uh if the Subspace are f is hard
using secrets of length M that where you
have to project the two Dimensions n
this is as hard as
the if this is hard then also the
standard assumption is hard so the
interesting thing is that the other
direction is also true basically so if
the this n this standard problem with
secrets of length n is
hard then also this Subspace LW problem
that Maps into into subsets of into into
into into subspaces of Dimension n is
also hard and what do we lose okay so
the the the size of the of the adversary
is considered you don't lose anything
and did the so this this Epsilon here is
the error of the Subspace and this
Epsilon here is on the standard lwe it's
the same but plus something that depends
on the on the dimension of of
the that depends on the dimension of
the so on z q on on the elements that
you use okay this is maybe good enough
if Q is exponential or very big super
polinomial uh but not if Q is say two
for LPN but fortunately we can do a
little bit better so if we uh take a gap
between these Dimensions that we require
so I want that you map into dimension of
n plus d where D is I don't know 50 or
something then this problem is actually
as hard as the LW Assumption of
Dimension n and you only get an
additional factor in the eror which is
like exponentially small in in D so the
Q to the d q is the size of the field in
D so if you if you choose this this Gap
big enough depending on Q that you need
then you have a this shows us those
things are basically
equivalent sorry just and I'm saying the
same thing maybe a more clean way to say
it you can say for any Delta you will
get Epsilon Prime is Epsilon plus Delta
but then you would put n plus log one/
Delta I mean this is like more
consistent extract I'm just saying M you
will say for any Delta this thing is
Epsilon Prime is equal Epsilon plus
Delta as as long as you set n Prime to
be n log 1/
Del
yeah just for applications of
my okay so why what does this imply so
before I show you new construction what
what does this the fact that this
Subspace lwe samples are hard so I said
you before that there are tons of applic
applications of this lwe and LPN
assumptions so and many of these
assumptions they use the fact that the
samples of pseudo random that you get
from the Eld W Oracle but what happens
for example so except this okay this is
what the slwe cases gives you what for
examp what happens for example if now we
have this application that whose
hardness relies on on you know on on the
hardness of lwe but somehow the
adversary can kind of fix a few few bits
of the of this random Vector R so the
application has to fix the random Vector
R but maybe the adversary can control
this Source it's like a bit fixing
source so the element can can fix all
the elements of R except n elements so
this um
uh because the sub this is going to be
as hard as the Subspace lwe problem of
Dimension n so you have secrets of
length M the ad uh the adversary can fix
all the bits except an element so and
because this is as hard as this slw
problem of Dimension n your primitive
will stay secure even if the adversary
can fix all bits okay you you degrade in
security you basically fall back to the
security that is guaranteed by the LW
assumptions with secrets of length n
instead of n but you're still safe so
cavat the is we still have this error
Vector which also has to be random and
you cannot tamper with this so if if if
anything goes wrong with the randomness
for the error uh you you're dead but in
many cases for example the HB protocol
that we will see later you the the this
Randomness is sent over a channel and
maybe the adversary can tamper with it
and like set a few bits but not
everything and this this basically
implies that you're still safe even if
if this happens another thing is our
relate something that's called related
key attacks so in the related key
attacks you you have a crypto system
that has a secret ad
and what you can do
is uh if maybe you can somehow change
the secret maybe it's a smart cart you
can put it in a microwave flip a few
bits or something you can somehow change
the secret and then actually uh invoke
the the crypto primitive with this
slightly tampered secret so assume for
example what you can do is you have this
again the Primitive that is uh based on
the LW assumption and you have the
secret key is actually yeah the secret s
used used uh used for lwe and maybe the
adversary can somehow set the elements
of of S he can set all almost all
elements but like he can set all
elements but maybe not not n of them so
n of them will always be the original
ones and yeah the hardness of slw
Subspace LW implies that this is still
going to stay hard as hard as the
standard LW problem with secrets of bank
so this are just to illustrate like two
particular examples of what such
Subspace LW Oracle allows you to do here
is not
no no it says F can fix all but n
elements of uh of the secret how
it here you show that any one fix
Distribution on which has high entropy
and here saying you restrict
distributions to be the subspaces in
some SP sense but you allow the aders to
change it right so that's so this LW
assumption has been proven to be
extremely resilient to leakage so if you
have a secret s that stays the secret
stays always the same you leak something
and then so this is this
shows it's a completely orthagonal thing
this shows it's resilient to tampering
not so one is leakage this is resilient
to tampering it's here you actually
change the secret and another thing you
don't leak anything except what you get
from access but you actually tamper with
the
secret okay okay so let let me give the
proof proof sketch of this of this of
this theorem that I said before that uh
that okay if if the LW problem is hard
then also the Subspace LW problem out so
what what's the challenge here so the
challenges here we have access what we
have to do is we have we have ch access
to lwe Oracle that gives you samples of
this form so some secret s of length n
samples uh random vectors R adds error
and so on and you have to show how to
transform this so to prove this theorem
we have to show how to transform this
samples into samples of this form where
this XR and X s's are adversar chosen
with every with every sample for every
sample we have to do this transformation
and for all these samples this s hat has
has to stay the same it doesn't it has
to be random and stay the same used in
all the samples because it stays the
same in the in the Assumption and this R
hat has to be uniformly random in every
every new sample okay how do we do that
so that's the transformation how you
transform this s into this s hat of
course if you say it's a transformation
you don't actually do this in the
reduction because you don't know s but
that's what you that's how you what you
do is the following you sample random
Matrix r m * n Matrix some blinding
Vector B and you find this new s hat to
be R * S Plus B you don't know what s
hat is you don't know what s is but you
will you will generate samples of this
form using this sample s hat okay how do
you sample this R hat okay that's how
you do it so this is a this is a set
this is the set of solutions to this
equation so you have this these are all
y's that that so this are the inputs
from the adversary this is the r that
you chose here this is also inputs from
the adversary again again this R this is
this is the r that you get from the lwl
uh lwe sample and you just sample this R
hat randomly from all solutions uh to
this equation and this set is actually
nonempty if the rank of this Matrix XR *
s * R is at least n and actually you can
show you know if if the rank of this
here is at least n plus d which which
you we're guaranteed because that's that
we require from the adversary that he
only chooses uh matrices that have rank
n plus d and this R is uniformly random
you can actually show that the
probability that this has rank less than
n is at most basically two divided by Q
to D + one okay and then because you use
T samples you have this T up here okay
okay and now okay I showed you how to
sample this R hat I still have to say
how to sample this entire big thing so
the error E here will be exactly the
same error as you have here and that's
how you sample it basically so this term
here that's this term here is basically
the term you get from the lwe sample
plus some set Z that you can compute
from values you know and that's the Z
that you have so you know everything you
know our hat you know these values from
the adversary this B you have chosen
yourself and so on and you do some
linear algebra I can prove that this has
perfectly the right distribution so
that's the
reduction okay that's that's the first
part
yeah okay that's the first part of the
talk and now I come to an applic so I
showed you that this subpal W assumption
has like nice applications in terms of
you bit it immediately implies security
against like bit fixing sources or some
classes of related key attacks for all
existing existing schemes that are based
who security is based on the LW
assumption on the pseudo randomness of
these samples but you can also once you
know that this thing is hard you also
can come up with completely new
protocols so I will show you an
Authentication Protocol so what's an
Authentication Protocol so consider a
protocol where we have a it's a
symmetric Authentication Protocol we
have like
some uh some some uh some prover and
some verifier this sometimes called T
and reader whatever they share some so
symmetric setting they share some secret
key they communicate a little bit and
the at the end of the communication this
reader says Okay I I accept or
reject and of course the idea is
somebody who doesn't know the secret uh
secret and interacts with this uh with
the verifier shouldn't shouldn't be able
to make the verifier accept and there
are many different Notions for for the
security of this authentication attacks
the the weakest one is so-called passive
security so here you consider an
adversary who like in the first phase
can observe arbitrary many Comm uh
communication transcripts between this
uh Pro and the verifier including the
final decision of of the of the verifier
if he accepted or not so usually he
should always accept but maybe with a
small uh completeness error and in the
second phase then the adversary
interacts only with the with the
verifier and he tries to make him accept
and you say okay the adversary wins if
he actually can make the this this uh uh
this Pro or accept a stronger notion uh
is so-called security against active
attacks here the adversary also can
first like observe as many samples as he
wants but Additionally the adversary can
actually interact with this uh with the
prover so he can send challenges or
whatever to the prover and see see what
answers this uh this uh this verifier
gets not only not only like randomly
chosen uh challenges from the from the
from the verifier as normally and again
the second phase is the same okay and
the ideal notion that you us want to
have from this and the strongest Notions
of course security against men in the
middle attack so here you consider an
adversary who sits in between the reader
and the verifier he can arbitr interact
with those maybe schedule the messages
how he wants maybe concurrently and so
on and okay so there is also I guess
this concurrency which is in between in
the first place you know you can talk to
many provs in par kind of which is I
don't think it's a the same secret or no
no I mean you the attacker you yeah the
Prov in dependently talk to you yeah the
have the same secet you just have
independent
s SC paper right yes you can have
concurrent executions on because I think
Standard
Security work this
right this is a strongest so I mean
actually it's trival to achieve this
kind of security if you have like a prf
or something or even a Mac or so so this
is you just you know this the the the
Prov sends you random challenge you
evaluate the prf and that input and
you're done but what we doing this what
what I will do now is to try to get like
authentication protocols which are like
extremely efficient so basically they
just should use a few uh XRS and
ANS and what we will achieve is only
this active security so this uh and it's
actually open how to do efficient
authentication from from LPN so you can
do that is secure against men in the
middle attacks you can you can't do it
because it's a pseudo random generator
you can use ggm and then you have a prf
but that's not efficient so when I say
efficient what I mean is basically K * n
basic operations where K is some
parameter that such that the LPN
assumption with secrets of length K is
secure and N is some statistical
security parameter 100 so K * n xors or
NS that's what they allow that's
efficient okay um so there is a famous
protocol uh due to Hopper and Bloom so
they they propose this protocol actually
as a very Authentication Protocol that
even humans can can compute so even if
you have like a piece of paper with
secret you actually can do this in your
head or on piece of paper and uh this so
how does the protocol work so the
verifying the pro share is secret s the
verifier chooses a random a sends it
over and the prover sends basically back
the so the the this LPN sample so s
inner product of s and a plus this some
error E and the verifier checks if what
he gets from uh from the prover is
really the inner product of s and a of
course uh this has this has a very big
soundness error H sorry correctness
error because you know uh the verifier
will only accept with probability one
minus to so something more than 1 half
let say if T is 0.25 with probability
0.75 and it also has a a huge um uh so
this was the completeness error it also
has a hug soundness error because if I
just send a random random bit I the the
verifier will accept still with
probability one have but you can amplify
this so you can cut you can you can do
this in parallel like n times where N is
a statistical security parameter and
then you
save okay so that's what I just said and
this protocol issecure against passive
attacks so this weakest notion that I
showed you before and it's trivially
insecure against active
attacks and why is it insecure against
active attacks it's easy to see so
assuming so in active attack you can
query the prover in the first phase so
you just send him a where say the first
bit of a is one and all the other bits
are zero you get basically noisy inner
products of s * a uh s * a where a is
like this which basically is the first
bit of s plus some error and if you get
enough samples you can you you it will
be biased towards the first bit of s and
you've learned the first bit of s then
you do this with the second bit of s and
so on and you learn
it okay so uh subsequently like DS and
wise have uh proposed a protocol that is
called hp+ and achieves active security
so what they basically do is they add an
additional third round so in the first
round actually the prover chooses a
random B and sends it over to the
verifier from then on okay as in the HP
protocol the verifier chooses a sends it
back then you then you compute this here
so the inner product of some secret S1
with B some secret S2 with a at the
error and again the things as before
this is secure against active attacks
but not against men in the middle
attacks has three
rounds and uh let me see okay that's the
protocol
again and uh a breaks okay and that's a
very very cute security proof that I
will go through in for a few minutes uh
due to cats and shin
so they show The Following so assume I
have an adversary a who breaks this
active security of this protocol with
Advantage Epsilon so this adversary
expects first access to some uh to some
Pro
p and I do the so I run this adversary
and I do the following I choose S2
myself I have access to some LPN Oracle
which either gives me LPN samples or
uniform random junk and okay whatever I
get from the Oracle I sent to a this
made like I get like n samples with the
randomness I concatenate them send them
over to uh the adversary the adversary
sends me back some Matrix a I send the
this answer here to the to the adversary
we just computed as follows okay I know
S2 so I compute a * S2 where this is the
a I got from the verifier and the six is
whatever I got from my Oracle so these
are the the the elements which are
either random or yeah all this noisy in
the products that I got from the Oracle
in the second phase okay now the
adversary is on the left side and the
uh and he has to to to uh and we know
that he has Advantage Epsilon in
actually making the the verifier accept
so what you do is the adversary sends us
B we send the adversary back some random
A1 and he gives us some Z1 but of course
now we can't compute anything because we
don't know S1 so we kind of check if
this is a valid answer or not what we do
is we rewind the
adversary uh to this first phase and
sent him a new a different A2 and a
different Z2 and now assume that in fact
in the second face both this Z1 and Z2
would the the pro verifier would have
accepted both of the z1es which means
the Z1 and Z2 are of this form where
this E1 has low weight okay if I add
them together then this B * S1 which is
the same I rewind it but I only rewind
it to this point so we have two times
the same B it will cancel out what I get
is okay imagine here is equality not the
not a plus and here A Plus what I get is
this here so I take this term on the
other side of the equation and what I
get if I just okay this terms I know S2
I know so I add this to this term oh
sorry I add this to this term I get like
the sum of these two low weight vectors
and okay if if I what I get this low
weight I assume okay this this Oracle
that I had here really gave me LPN
samples so in this okay and we have
probability Epsilon Square I will accept
and in case this x is uniformly random
then in fact what you get in the first
phase the Zs are independent of the
secret S2 that I chose and you can show
that in this in this in this case the
probability so this because okay because
I will accept if this has low weight and
because the adversary has no clue about
S2 and if this has sufficiently high
rank this this thing here will basically
uniformly random this thing here so if
the adversary chooses Ed Z1 Z2 it's very
unlikely that this will end up in a low
weight Vector so exponentially small
probability so anyway um there has been
like tons of followup work on protocols
who try to make this protocol active
secure and then other Pro uh against
secure against men middle attacks and
the other papers that break this
again so this is from this
website okay and those Protocols are all
HP uh about protocols that are HP or
like extensions so I showed you hp+
there was like HB sharp h++ and others
okay now I'll show a protocol which is
completely different than it's it's not
the HP style protocol and has two rounds
and works as follows so we again have a
verifier and approver they have a secret
of length Okay so we have some
parameters parameter K chosen such that
the LPN problem with of with secrets of
length K and some security error noise
tab is hard okay I Define l to be
slightly more than two * K okay and N is
a statistical security parameter the
secret is of length to L and is shared
between two so what the verifier now
does so in the HP protocol he choose a
random random Vector R to be taken as
the inner product now he does something
else now he chooses a vector v which has
is length to L and has weight has
exactly L1 at a random V on you
constrained on the on the fact that it
has weight L Pro verify senses over to
the prover what does the prover do he
samples the error Vector a okay a random
Matrix so think for the moment that this
is just a random
element random Vector of length L and he
takes the inner product of this random r
with SV what is SV SV is this this if
you have the secret s and you delete all
the elements where V is that's what I
call SV so it's like basically this V
defines like a subset of s and you take
the inner product of of of this this
this random random Vector r with this
subset of s and add the arrow e to it
okay and you do this actually n times in
parallel basically so you choose the r
which is like n vectors of length L and
you take the inner product with this
subset n time and you add this Arrow
Vector of like e ROM
elements e noise noise elements each one
biased towards one you send this over to
the verifier what does the verifier do
he checks if this Matrix R has actually
full rank which it will have almost
certainly if it's chosen randomly and
then yeah it checks if what what what is
the weight
of of this term here so what should of
so it takes the Zs and adds basically
this term here RT * SV to it and if
computed correctly this should have
weight roughly n * to because there's n
elements this this this is basically so
this basically be the arrow Vector which
should have roughly weight n * to so if
if it's significantly more than this so
to Prime is some some constant which is
bigger than to and smaller than half if
it's significantly better uh if it's
significantly larger than this then I
reject otherwise I
accept and that's that's the the theorem
so if uh if the learning LPN problem
with security with secrets of length K
is hard then actually the active
security of this protocol is basically
the same Epsilon okay Min is something
exponentially small in in this
statistical security parameter so the
constant here depends on on basically on
Tow and on how much bigger than two this
is so but
it's
okay uh okay I want to do a proof of
this Blackboard but I think I'm running
out of time anyway so I think I ski that
but the proof is really cute the proof
is okay so let me
conclude so I showed you a new adaptive
assumption for which like similar to the
new adaptive assumption which is
equivalent to the learning with errors
problem uh so as one application I
showed you like a new protocol oh okay I
should maybe say a few things about this
protocol so why is this better than HB
plus so for one thing it has one round
less so it's two round which I think
it's for the for the goal of this
protocol which is like this High
efficient highly efficient
Authentication Protocol for RFID tax I
think this makes makes a difference
because actually it's probably even
going to be four rounds if you use hp+
because you have to take tell to the to
the to the tag that you now want to
start the interaction and you has to
send you something you something and so
on okay it's rewindable for the verifier
that's HP plus it's also not and it has
a tight security reduction so you see it
here is Epsilon and what you got before
with this rewind so there's no rewinding
going on in the proof what you did
before with the rewinding gave you
Epsilon
squared okay so I showed you this new
protocol we also have a a very efficient
Mac from uh LPN but it's not really a
Mac it's it's a randomized Mac and it's
only satisfies a Veer security notion
where you not allowed to actually ask
for verification queries for for Max for
messages that you have already received
so you cannot get a Mac and slightly
change something and ask if it's still
valid so but okay you can still
authenticate communication with this in
in a passive
setting of course the question is what
else can we do from this adaptive
assumption so thank you
time for your
questions can you put the
Assumption the the definition of the
Assumption yeah
okay
so the adversary has to um so when does
the adversary choose
RNs so s is like in the Box s is secret
okay so now it's it's you make a query
so the adversary makes the
query it ches R right it ches r no the
Box ches R so so what what is the
Adaptive Point who chose this the
Adaptive part is the projections this
this matrices XR X so you choose you you
look at this and say I'd like to have
like in a product in this Subspace you
know please project this secret into
this Subspace and the random art that
you will choose into this Subspace to
and compute in the product
there okay so it chooses and they
chooses
many
yeah just for each query we require that
the overlap of the this this these two
projections overlap in N Dimension sub
because otherwise if they overlap in the
onedimensional Subspace then yeah he
could for example cancel out everything
and just keep the first bit of s
so so just wonder if there's a way to
formulate this as kind of one way
function that you can ask
for
function it's probabilistic right so
even if you make the same query twice
you get different
outputs okay
are you allowed to make the same I'm
aren't you going to get something you
know very close to each other I
mean LW is is always the same
thing so is right this is syntactic
question yes I'm sorry R is in zq to R
is big and then it's projected down to
zq to the N yeah the real question uh if
if u p is R * XR so you write
multiply right then the problem becomes
it's equal to right so that's so U but
it's adap it's adaptive right it's not
that the the point is in of course if
you just multiply one and the so you you
going to take pfr in a product with PFS
right so that is uh XR * R transpose *
XS * s okay
so take one
more this was here yes yes good
um so so that's going to be R transpose
time XR big XR Matrix XR time big Matrix
XS Time s trans uh so so that's why the
matri is kind of come in between the r
and s and that's what makes it kind of
different from uh you think you cannot
push it to the other side or yeah I
cannot you cannot push it to the other
that's yeah yeah you see that's that's
basically yeah yeah you have basically r
on the left s on the right and this
thing in the middle if you
want so yes it's it's bit redundant here
I feel you probably could uh probably
it's equivalent if you K if you if you
leave out one of this x I'm not sure
well if you put the XR on the right it's
equivalent and Xs on the right it's
equivalent that's probably not the
simplest it's probably not the
simplest
I it's probably not the shortest thing
maybe you can maybe you can compress
this somehow into one Matrix probably
you can't I just care about the product
but it's probably I think if the
adversary just send this it's it's it's
the same but I think it's easier to
think about this that you project maybe
it's not but the I thought it's easier
to think about it pro R and
S instead of having a r on the left s on
the right and then some this this thing
here some Matrix in the middle I don't
exactly know what this means
so I know it's the same as the other
thing
but and you right away get negligible
soundness right because in the orinal DU
wi sequential repetition so C have to
show your thing already has negligible
sound to begin this right because you
know the point is it's Big M you right
away par but I have to do right away par
and the reason is the
following you see oh this is the
protocol the reason is the following um
so cats and Chin like the HB plus you
have like this basic round which is like
a gap between sound is in complet and
here and then you in
parallel if now assume I would do just a
basic ground you just choose this one R
here and then you repeat this in
parallel that's not secure because I
need you know this is like so because
you have this additional constraint that
the if if you repeat it end times you
would have to put the additional
constraint that the RS chosen by by the
Prov he can't he can't choose you know
he can be malicious and he can't choose
like a diagonal Matrix or something it
doesn't I'm not I cannot force him to
choose randomly but I need that the rank
is big enough so basically he has to you
can do something slightly different you
can uh what you can do is you can you
can actually skip this check and make
the secret end bits longer or you don't
even need that uh and bit longer and put
the identity Matrix in front here so
then you kind of enforce that you always
have Rank and and but basically the
first n n elements you can't pre-compute
them they're always going to it's not
going to be less efficient because it's
always going to be the same Vector that
you basically add and another thing is
here the prover has to check that this V
really has weight
L and you can also get so this is might
not be if you want to do it an RFID this
might not be very efficient but you can
get around this and add some have secret
V Prime that you always add to it and
the proof gets a bit more complicated
and it's not going to be the weight of
the XR is not going to be exactly oh but
it still
goes the fixing attack thing is so
protecting against bid fixing attacks is
kind of trivial right I mean uh so if I
if I fix a whole bunch of bits of R
coefficients of R then that's that's
like leaving these coefficients of s out
yeah but again you can do it adaptively
I can do query I can yeah yeah I can I
can fix some bits here and then I get
the sample in the next in the next
invocation I fix other bits of R and I
get the sample
andriv the really thing the real thing
here is that makes it I think a bit
surprising that this is equivalent is
the adaptivity if you just would have
you know if the adversary chooses this
matrices once and that's then we use it
all all that's that's would not be not
be use and I wouldn't see how it would
be useful also it's the adaptivity that
makes
it makes it
useful one more Qui
question let's thank the speaker
again all right uh our next speaker is y
Ken do from NYU talking
about talking about um cryptography
against continuous memory attacks thanks
uh how do I put up my slides okay so uh
I'm going to talk about uh leakage
resilient
cryptography um and just kind of a quick
motivation is probably unnecessary here
but I'll just run through it anyway so
traditionally in cryptography we assume
a very nice kind of abstractions that
secret keys are perfectly secure so for
example when you use publicy
cryptography public key the adversary
only sees public key but there is some
kind of wall so the secret key is really
in the safe and there is a very well
defined interface between uh the way you
know what kind of usages of the secret
keys that attacker can see maybe he can
see exactly signatures maybe some Cipher
text but you know he can see precisely
things that the protocol wants attacker
to see in some well- defined adversarial
model and of course in practice
ironically I you know I'm not putting uh
references but there are million of
references I wouldn't have on the slide
uh in reality most cryptography is
actually broken not because somebody
breaks RSA or factoring but because of
some security things that's why security
gets much more like Federal funding and
so on uh not because it's like
scientifically deeper but because you
know that's unfortunately what happens
in practice uh you know you get all
kinds of like side Channel attacks you
know there is this cold boot attack
which received a lot of attention from
Princeton and of course there are all
kinds of hackers and so on so what those
guys do typically the secret key sits uh
maybe on some server or on some smart
card or something like that and then one
way or another the attacker gets all
kinds of sneaky geeky machines like
thermometers and electromagnetic things
so whatever some things that you know
when you design crypto system we don't
really think of it's some weird stuff
which is really outside the model and
usually one way or another through this
weird stuff which is completely outside
our idealized model thater gets partial
and you know unfortunately in some cases
even complete information about the
secret key so until recently even though
kind of you know there are a lot of you
know almost anything in cryptography you
can kind of you know relate it to
leakage but until recently essentially
the usual response of cryptographers is
look what can we do I mean I don't know
about thermometers or you know
electromagnetic W waves I'm not going to
write papers with like thermometers and
you know the model or something like
that so uh it's not really our program
look we have a clean model you guys who
have electrical engineers or uh
programmer or security guys or Firefall
experts or guys uh you know security
guards downstairs you you really have to
do a better job to make sure that our
keys are not stolen uh so this is kind
of uh you know of course those guys says
look it's inevitable something get
stolen so anyway so probably what you
guys proof is anyway relevant so there
is this blame game uh but recently uh I
guess it has been this dedicated effort
from a cryptographic community to
develop this leish resilient
cryptography and to say look let's try
to help of course we're not going to get
to the low level uh details how
exactly uh you're going to uh you know
get information about the secret key and
so we'll try to be as general as we can
um but let's let let's set this uh
highly adversarially specified leakage
to the idealized adversarial attack
model and I'll talk about it in the next
few slides there are many options how to
do it and then what we want to do after
we add this welldefined kind of leakage
Oracle but still adversar chosen leakage
Oracle um to our model we want to design
Primitives which are P provably secure
even if the adversary see some leakage
of the secret key and hopefully this
will allow us to bridge the gap between
theory and practice and you know this is
an active young field it remains to be
seen how far it can bridge the gap but
it's kind of a very highly promising
Direction and I'm excited about it so
how do we model leakage well the start
is easy abstractly as theoreticians
let's start with a theory we will give
the attacker um what we call a lickage
Oracle so there is this owl or whatever
it is that will know the secret key and
the attacker can specify some function f
without loss of reality to a bit because
maybe you can call the Oracle multiple
times and you'll just get one bit of
secret you know the function of the
secret key and of course you can say
okay great I mean give me first bit of
the secret key give me second bit of the
secret key I mean you're not going to
prove any security so naturally we some
who need to restrict the leakage such
the AER doesn't get get secret keing
full and you know uh one of the stupid
comments I got in a grand application
when I wrote something like that people
you know somebody says oh it's like a
theoretician how can you do it what does
attacker get something in full well
that's kind of a stupid comment but
still let me uh yeah I mean look
unfortunately we cannot do magic we
cannot do everything so if somehow you
really don't protect your secret key
that you know the attacker is power
powerful enough to get it in full uh
there is nothing maybe you can do but at
least if it's reasonable and some of the
attacks actually don't get the key in
full because maybe they don't get full
access they just measure some
temperature or something like that it
would be very nice to kind of say
something probably secure about that so
uh what it means it justifies that if
you want to actually put cryptography
and provable security here we have to uh
put some restrictions on the kind of AIS
and naturally there are two kinds of
dimensions of restrictions that we can
put so one I'll talk about it on the
next slides but roughly the First
Dimension is um to bounce the number of
queries during various stes of the
attacks so kind of you learn maybe one
bit so you don't learn too much and also
maybe uh the second kind of orthogonal
direction is maybe restrict the type of
leakage function maybe you can you know
compute only like low complexity
functions or some noisy functions or
something I'll give you some examples in
a
second uh and uh so this is kind of
abstractly what we are going to do so
let me talk a little bit more about the
Slick model and from the purposes of the
stock I want to make the following
distinctions the first distinction is
the last two bullets of the slides I'm
going to distinction uh to make a
distinction between restricted attacks
versus memor so kind of green is better
than red throughout the slides um so
restricted I'm not putting references
I'll put references at the end if I have
time uh but people kind of consider well
maybe that AR physical bits like uh well
in Christ's case it was more more like
tempering but uh you know it was work
like physical bits maybe it's some kind
of low complexity circuit something for
example in complex called AC Z circuit
so you cannot compute even parity or
something like that uh a very popular
aium or variance of this aums is this
only computation leaks information so
for example if you don't touch part of
the secret key you cannot click on that
secret key um um and you know variance
of the ex like independent lickage and
so on and so on so this is also very
very interesting typ type of work um
well the problem is of course it's not
you know fully General and the second
problem kind of really forces you to be
to still do proofs with respect to you
know somewhat particular kinds of things
you need to know how this secret key
stored in memory and so on and of course
there is this memory what I called
memory leakage where you know I will say
look any efficient function f is legal
I'm not going to place any restrictions
uh so definitely if we can protect here
I'm in great shape um and of course the
second very big distinction which is you
know recently started to be kind of more
pronounced but um you know it definitely
is a very important
distinction so inally I will call it one
time versus continual leakage so so one
time it doesn't mean that you can call
the Oracle only one times but
essentially just means that there is an
a priority upper bound on how many times
you call um the Oracle throughout the
lifetime of the system so overall there
is some leakage we call it leakage
parameter capital L and you can call the
Oracle at most like capital L times and
usually let's say capital L is less than
the length of the secret or something
like that uh right so this is what I
call one time schemes and continuous
leakage schemes um so let's change our
model I don't it's realistic still maybe
if my scheme is used for a while you
know eventually the attacker will get
more information of the secret key so
this model is kind of interesting it's
uh it's very you know it leads to some
beautiful Theory uh but still this model
might not be applicable there are some
relaxations of this model something
called bound retrieval model and so on
but still this assumption in the long
run is going to be
problematic uh so the second line it
relaxes the model a little bit to
achieve stronger security you can say
you know what we're going to
periodically refresh the secret key
so you know initially let's say I will
draw it kind of in different colors so
initially I had this red secret key then
somehow after a while I think well you
know maybe too much of the secret key is
kind of leaked maybe it's safe I should
refresh my secret key so now it becomes
kind of green maybe I'll refresh it
again it becomes yellow and so on so
there in between the refreshes you still
will necessarily bounce the number of
lickage queries so the amount of
information that AER can get about the
secret key but you can see look if I
refresh frequently enough and I'll talk
more about refreshing in a second this
is how realistic but overall the overall
leakage of the system is not leaked so
this is really what practitioners if you
talk to ad Shamir or other people uh
also in practice uh uh you know I talk
to various people this is really this is
a model where you know I contribute it a
lot of you know works but uh it's a nice
theoretical model but in practice I mean
it's useful for this model but really
this is a model that you know
practitioners want because this is what
realistic such chel attacks um do okay
so kind of to summarize we have this two
large larger orthogonal there is some
intersection but largely orthogonal
Dimensions you know one time versus
continuous restricted versus memory
attacks and very roughly there was there
was a lot of work especially recently
starting from a 90 10 you can see a lot
of references here to this years and I I
cannot like really cover all this work
uh but there has been a lot of very very
interesting beautiful work um on all
kinds of things uh but unfortunately so
far um you know uh this corner
uh was pretty much untouched I mean I
will talk about what was known but not
much AK a authenticated key agreement
okay yes authenticated if hel or
something like that yeah so uh so
essentially really if I want if I don't
want to worry about loing computation
leaks information something completely
unrestricted leakage but I want to have
continuous things of the secret key kind
of updates nothing was known so far and
this is what we tried to achieve in this
work so can we achieve The Best of Both
Worlds and throughout the stock that's
what I'm going to call CLR doesn't mean
coroners and ravest it means uh uh you
know continuous leakage resilience so
this is a model um that you know we're
going to try to get the first scheme in
this model
okay so um I'll just to recap our model
of continuous leakage resilience uh I
mean I kind of said it but let's be
precise because there was all this
random references and so on um the
secret key will be updated it will be
updated only using local Randomness so I
don't want like any external servers so
like time periods or something like that
just I myself on my computer you know
ideally hopefully using good Randomness
will uh Locker refresh my secret key
other users they do not need to know
that updates exist they do not need to
know how frequent they are I don't need
to do updates periodically it's
completely up to me if I think I'm more
compromised I will update more
frequently if I think you know I've been
sitting at home and didn't do much I
will not update is completely up to me
in particular the public key doesn't
change right because other people don't
know so definitely I canot change public
key so for other people they don't know
it's totally my own local maintenance
procedure to periodically refresh my
secret key and no time periods no no
synchronized clocks nothing like that
okay so clean model like that uh number
as I said number of leakage queries will
be bounded by this parameter L which
will be less than the secret key um in
between the updates but there is no
bound over the lifetime of the system
and update is not there's no leakage
during update I'll talk about it so I
mean everything I you know work very
hard everything I think I will be very
surprised if there is a question which
is not answered on the slide but still
feel free to answer questions uh to ask
questions so uh there will be no
restrictions on the time of leakage so
this will be Memory attack so and
intuitive where we will get our security
that adversary you know when he breaks
in now he cannot predict my future
Randomness um so for example he cannot
do this you know future this kind of
pretty unrealistic attack that you will
kind of break in compute what would my
key be like 20 years from now whatever
like and then for every new kind of
break in compute the next bit of my
secret key 20 years from now so very
important question to for the Tom asked
uh do we allow leakage during key
updates in practice it's extremely
important that we allow leakage during
key update but in our schemes our final
scheme uh we have it I'll talk about it
but in the basic model we'll already
have our hands full with a model where
we will not allow any leakage during key
updates as you'll see it's still high
and nonrival because it's completely
local there is no external server um and
so on and the keys still have to remain
functional I canot just wipe out my
secret key because you know it has to
correspond to a public key it has to
remain functional so it's not a trivial
thing but for now let's assume that the
updates a leak free and I will show you
a completely General theorum which will
kind of allow us to generically go from
this model to the model where we allow
some leakage during ke updates but for
now this is great question and of course
another thing we definitely don't want
our schemes uh to have efficiency which
kind of degrades even logarithmically
with a number of
updates yeah refesh you erase the past C
that's actually good point yes so I do
assume erasers yeah asse well I mean
even if I have yeah I mean formally
perfect erasers but you can kind of puts
imperfect imperfectness of erasers into
this leakage L you can say look I assume
every time I erase maybe like seven bits
of my secret key is not leaked so this
can be kind of formally modeled that you
know I decrease L by seven on the
attacker also learns so you can you can
do so but yeah I I assume you know
perfect ER so any question this actually
very important so I try to be as precise
as I could about the model but it's very
important that they get it good um so uh
so the was maybe other works but the
most kind of central work with most
relevant to our problem so nothing was
known is first observation we had in
crypto 2 years ago where we kind of
designed these onetime schemes um you
you know in the me again memory attacks
and we notice that it's very trivial to
have a variant of CLR signatures where
the updates require external master key
which never leaks so this master key is
only used like I put it on some you know
external CD or something like that and I
don't need it to run regular operations
like regular signatures and so on but
when I do updates maybe I go offline or
something like that and I just refresh
my secret key and it's actually not
completely Tri transformation but uh but
it's PR pretty simple it's just pretty
simple way to take a regular signature
scheme and a onetime secure signature
scheme you know one time leakage
resilience signature scheme and compose
them together I'll let you think about
it but it's pretty
simple um so and then there is a very
nice paper that I mention a little bit
at the end of by not and others also in
the upcoming FKS but the initial kind of
results that we knew before we started
our work they kind of had a you know I
would say Semitic indication that maybe
actually this remarkable primitive of
continuous liage resilience is possible
so they give a construction of CLR
signatures uh based on a pretty strong
nonstandard
assumption um which for technical
reasons they kind of you know use the
hash function inside this assumption but
uh even if the hash function is modeled
as a random Oracle you for technical
reasons cannot prove security but you
can make a highly nonstandard assumption
about pcps and so on that will kind of
uh shows that some extremely inefficient
CLR signatures might EX exist so it kind
of give us some hope but it's definitely
inefficient uh so it's kind of you know
was a big question you know can you
actually really do something useful so
our results uh so we build CLR schemes
under the standard assumptions well the
assumption is uh called Kline assumption
which is by now a standard assumption by
linear group so we we will use you know
a little bit of pairing separation uh
but as I said well I'll mention it on
the next bullets uh so in the best
schemes we can Le up to one half of the
secret ke key in between our updates all
the schemes are really practically
efficient they well they use pairings
but essentially any scheme you know take
a scheme which you sparing sub scheme
will be essentially as efficient as that
scheme maybe like 20% slow or something
like that uh but it's really it's not
like some theoretical thing it's a
Concrete very very efficient schemes
okay um uh and which are additionally
continuous leakage resilient and even
though this application is kind of the
main application the way we derive this
application we build this primitive
which is the most basic cryp graphic
primity which is useful but by itself
maybe not that interesting which is one
way relation which I'll talk about the
next slide and once we build one way
relation we will uh plug in previous
Machinery which is you know non-al
Machinery but we will plug in Machinery
previous machinery and kind of argu that
it works with our stuff and you get this
more advanced application which is
interesting stuff but I you know I
really want to tell you where a novelty
so we'll really concentrate largely on
this continuous leage resilient oneway
relation for much of the top so let me
tell you the definition it's kind of you
can guess it but let me be explicit so
that we on the same
page so uh is uh a oneway relation in
general is you know there is a key
generation procedure that outputs a
secret key and a public key okay and you
know there is a verification procedure
some relation R which kind of checks if
the secret key really will open the
public key and you know under normal
circumstances it should open so that's
great but the attacker who doesn't know
who only gets the publicy
it's very hard as computationally hard
to find any secret key visual satisfies
the relation right it's kind of
visualization of one-wayness but instead
of one way functions we talk about
relations General relations as opposed
to functions all right so this is a
standard notion of security so what we
will want we will want to have uh CLR
relations so we will also want to have a
new procedure which didn't exist before
which is this randomization procedure
which uses only local Randomness which
allows us to R randomize a secret key
all right and uh and the correctness
should be the new key the green key
should still verify so you know you want
to do it you know and you can do it as
many times as we want you know the
efficiency shouldn't be great kind of
and all those green red blue whatever
other colors all the keys should be good
so this is just kind of correctness the
new kind of correctness requirements
good so what about security the security
is exactly what you would expect so the
attacker starts with maybe the red key
he can ask up to L queries about the red
guy you know what's the second beit what
is like the third bit of sha two of the
secret key what's like Fast FIA
transform like you know 17th bit of
something like that you know collect
this information get this part of the
secret key now the key for now is
securely refreshed but as I said we'll
add Randomness you know leakage during
Randomness later but for now it's
perfectly securely refreshed it becomes
green the attacker again asks question
it gets uh this you know green guy then
the key is refreshed to Yellow it gets
you know parts of the yellow guy and for
arbitrary polinomial number of periods
he get this information so the total
leakage could be unbounded right it's
just bounded in between the periods
right and now the attacker does some
magic thing he tries
to combine the keys you you know to form
a meaningful key and shouldn't be able
to succeed okay so this is a notion of
continuous liage resilient one hopefully
very natural notion so we trying to kind
of you know abstract really the novelty
okay any questions
okay good so uh very briefly kind of
informally what's the difficulty in
constructing One Way relations well
aside from the fact that they have it
hasn't been done um so in reduction if
you think about it you know you need to
know many secret keys in full because
intuitively how else would you simulate
leakage if you don't know the secret key
in full and you should be able to to you
know answer orbitary function you kind
of need to know many valid secret keys
right uh nevertheless when the attacker
forges when the attacker can of forges a
secret key for the relation you need to
solve some hard problem all right so
intuitively what you want to hope you
hope that some who a forgery is of a
different types that the kind of key
that you
know right but the doer gets unbounded
amount of information in total so inly I
mean how do you ensure that through this
overall unbounded number of information
the attacker doesn't learn the kind of
type of the key that you know yeah the
signature Paradox in some sense it's
it's similar to the signature Paradox
except here in some sense it's you know
well I would T it's even harder uh
because you know there is this leakage
queries but yeah it's kind of for the
signature you need to be able to force
signatures of messages and yet from a
new you know message uh you can do stuff
but you know there you can do more stuff
you can change public keys and the
reduction so here kind of the in some
sense the public has to stay the same
but it's very similar indeed we manage
to overcome this difficulty I'm just
kind of pointing out you know the
difficulty and at least in particular n
you know previous techniques kind of
would fail precisely let's say previous
technique for onetime leakage you know
won't extend precisely for this
difficulty right so this is kind of the
but you know we'll solve it and
hopefully I'll try to uh you know tell
you how we'll solve it in a general way
before go getting into specific
assumptions this is the outline first I
will uh tell you a general strategy
which in some sense will be the heart of
kind of how to go from continuous
leakage to onetime leakage to more
complicated problem one time leakage
that was previously known how to solve
but still would be one time leakage then
will show how to H relatively
specialized but still General
constructions that if you have special
encryption and non interactive zero
knowledge proofs we would be able to uh
you know solve this onetime leakage
problem and finally I will show you an
efficient instantiation of these
components based on this
assumption to to
not just
bit become easier yeah a bit leakage is
kind of it's definitely with secure
updated Thal you can use a generically
for any PR if you can use something
colonizing transform you store something
big and um uh and then you know that if
the attacker learn few bits a real
secret is kind of secure so yeah for
bits bits like just yeah and refresh is
like from fresh recompute the secret and
encode it again St at least without
leakage of random the refresh the
refresh so during the refresh I'll show
some general theorum but uh uh I'm
pretty sure in 5 minutes we'll come up
with a scheme like that you know
with General function that's really is
the difficulty yeah I mean not just bits
as opposed to you know anything else
yeah completely General functions
yeah so uh all right so let's start with
this so I'm going to give you so this is
a strategy so this is a little bit uhu I
think the definition is very natural but
essentially I'm going to tell you if I
can define a special kind of oneway
relation which has some special
properties it will automatically be
continuous leage secure okay so what is
the kind of relation so imagine this is
a space of all possible secret keys and
the will be and you know we can always
given a relation have this blue set of
valid secret Keys those are secret Keys
is just verify this is a set of valid
secret Keys technically any of this
secret key is verified but somehow
secretly there will be two this set will
be partition into good Keys green keys
and Bad Keys red keys right so we'll
have to design some scheme that is kind
of the secret key is kind of secretly
partition on two sets and um in during
key generation not only do we sample
public key and secret key but we can
sample three keys which are only used in
proofs of security but they're not used
kind of in the scheme but we can kind of
sample three keys we can sample a s samg
key which intuitively allow us to sample
a random good key we can sample SB which
is kind of some key which intuitively
allow us to sample a random bad key and
we can also sample a trapo so that we
can actually which actually can tell
them apart so that you know just which
essentially defines what is good and
what is bad
right so what are the white keys in the
picture or oh this this invalid so this
is just a space zero1 to the you know if
the secret key is 1,000 this is this is
just all possible key this is the key I
don't verify I mean they will disappear
very shortly it's just just saying this
is a global set of the domain of keys
yeah secret Cas good so uh right
so DK is the key which allows me to
actually to test given a valid secret
key will tell me is it is it green it's
just to formally what it what what does
green and red mean actually I mean DK is
a formal way to define what green and
red actually means good and also of
course and we need the syntactic
property which allow us to randomize we
still need this is already exist in CLR
we need to be able to randomize actually
green keys so given a Green Key using
local Randomness I can I should be
intuitively able to sample a completely
fresh green key so intuitively this
procedure rent which is exactly the
procedure which we'll use uh actually if
it happens to get key which is good it's
not going to sample maybe it's actually
going to sample essentially a random uh
good key so that's the kind of
restriction uh you know that we will put
in our Rand procedure okay okay so is it
clear so this is a kind of this is a
kind of I'll tell you security
properties in a second but this is the
kind of syntactic properties that I want
for
now yep any
questions should hold oh no no security
properties yet I'll put them on the next
slide so there is no security this is
just simp for now okay now
security so uh I want like two
complimentary properties hardness of
good casys and hardness of bad casys the
hardness of good key says that even if I
give you essentially a way to you can
sample yourself orbitary many red keys
if you want I give you a sampling key
for red Keys it's computationally hard
to get a Green Key so given not just
even it's not like I just give you red
key I even give you you can sample as
many as you want red Keys you cannot get
a Green Key and the other way around
right so this keys are kind of from one
is hard to get to the so in some sense
very difficult okay I mean very
different from each other and the new
property which is in some sense all
properties are important in the proof as
you will see but this is really the key
property that will allow us to push
stuff forward we call it leakage IND
distinguishability property and leacy
distinguishability property says that
you know the adversary get public and he
can sample both good and Bas he can do
you know whatever he wants behind my
back I sample it's essentially you'll
say that red keys look like are
indistinguishable from G keys I will
pick at random one of the keys okay and
I don't give you it in full but you can
get up to L bits of lickage about the
key that I picked behind my back so you
can learn a lot of information but not
all of the information and then you
output an orbitary key as a key SK star
and you win if SK star is in the same
category as the key behind my back so
entally you're trying to guess which key
I picked behind my back but you don't
see it completely you do you see this
well of course just kind of of to make
sure that you follow what's the problem
if you see it completely I claim this
property is impossible to
satisfy you just copy the key right and
so just you know just to make sure why
it's not rval yeah of course so there is
right so this is uh but with leakage
leakage and distinguishability will kind
of say but it it really doesn't say it
doesn't say that it's hard like to copy
my key it really says you cannot
correlate because you can sample
arbitrarily your own Keys you really
cannot kind of uh you know correlate
intuitively it says that you cannot
correlate the category of your key the
on that you come up because notice you
cannot even test yourself if your key is
green and red you know red but you um
you know you cannot correlate it with a
hidden
key yeah we thinking about leakage
nonability
it's just nonability you know it focuses
on one aspect but we really wanted to
emphasize because it's both in
distinguishability and unability so uh
in some sense yeah it has aspects of
both we felt like in distinguishability
is a more important thing to stress
at least for the intuition but
yeah yeah you can you need another
distribu property from the previous
slide right no oh yeah this is uh it
will be statistical but yeah this is I
view it a correctness property but yeah
sure I view it more as a correctness
property yeah on the previous slides
that if you just randomize the secret
key you get a fresh key but yeah you you
you can view it as security property but
I view it as a correctness property I
mean there is no attacker it's just you
know good all right so now I claim so we
call it in distinguishable randomizable
relation uh short Long Island Railroad L
and the important thing look this is a
really weird primitive say what I mean
you have this beautiful continuous liage
resilient oneway relation you know
natural definition exactly what you want
now you give me this new trors and so on
the important thing is that this weird
new property is a onetime property and I
claim and as we will see as I'll show
you next slide anything which is like
this weird one satisfy this weird time
one time property I can do a hybrid
argument to get a reusable property okay
so let's see the proof it's actually
very simple intuitively it it is really
simple so let's start with the real
experiment for continuous leakage
resilience so the attacker sees you know
only good Keys We randomize essentially
we start with a Green Key and you know
we keep randomizing it it always is
inside the green stuff and you get
leakage on these things and so on and
then eventually come up with a forgery
okay so I claim that your fory must be a
good key why because look if you only
green keys and then you output a red key
you broke hardness of red keys right
from only green Keys you can come you
came up with a red key that should be
hard right so the forgery should be red
this is our first property now I'm kind
going to play this hybrid game with the
adversary one by one I'm just going to
switch you know a keep from green to Red
just one by one I'm going to make these
hybrids games where I just switch one
key from good to bad and I'll see CE
that AER notices and I claim but leakage
in distinguishability the forgery every
time I do one one switch like that the
forgery should still remain good so it's
kind of unlikely that you know I switch
one ke from Red from green to red and
previously the attaka forged a Green Key
and now suddenly the attaka forges a red
key he said look assume he does it that
contradicts liage in distinguishability
because the only difference between
these two Wells is that one key
essentially I picked one key behind my
back you got L bits of leakage about the
key and suddenly you managed to Output
the key in a different category kind of
you correlated with the categories that
I had essentially you initially it was
green and now I changed it to Red you
started to get red so this is exactly
leakage and distinguishability and of
course you say wait a second how do I
get this other Keys remember l in
distinguishability holds even if you
have your own sampling keys so those
those keys in these Keys you can sample
yourself right so this is intuitively so
leakage in distinguishability will allow
you to do this hybrid argument and
finally all the keys are red but the
forgy Still Remains green but that will
contradict the hardness of good Keys cuz
now in this hybrid experiments all the
leakage is from the red keys but you
still Forge a Green Key and that's a
contradiction because green keys are
hard to get from Red Keys all right so
this is uh any questions about
this all right so anyway so this is
maybe abstract I'm sorry it's you know
it's a but you know it really took us a
while to abstract this properties this
maybe looks trivial at the end but it
really simplified us to kind of present
our construction this way so now the
construction based on pic um so this is
the outline of the construction so we're
going to use some magical two magical
encryption schemes and you know non
interactive so and I apologize hopefully
you'll get at least if you get even that
part up up to now it's fine uh I think
the construction is natural but you know
unfortunately it is you know slow and
Technical um but it's intuitive so
anyway I have two public encryption
schem you know and special non
interactive zero knowledge proof and
here is the syntax of My
Le so my public key will be you know
Common reference string for zic it will
be two public keys and a cipher text
essentially my public key is encryption
of a random message so ignore those
other public Keys a public key is
encryption of a random message okay the
syntax of the secret key will contain
another CER Tex in a proof and
intuitively valid secret keys will say
C2 encryp the same message so C1 and C2
encrypt the same
message but maybe they don't really
encryp it but the proof verifies so
valid secret Keys means that P really
proves that C1 and C2 are encryptions of
the same message okay so public is
encryption one of the message and
intuitively a secret key should be
encryption two of this message and
approve that this is a good encryption
so a good secret key will actually mean
that they really encrypt the same
message so if you actually decrypt you
get it's not just the proof verifies
because maybe it's a fake proof maybe
somebody forc the proof proof but it
really means that they decry the same to
the same
message
okay and I claim you can sample very
easily from this thing with a trapdor
which is M&R so if I give you the
message and the randomness used to
encryp this thing you know the message
you just encrypt the message under the
second key yourself you have the witness
R is a witness so you generate the proof
yourself honestly so you can easily
sample fresh secret keys right using
this stor you can sample fresh secret
keys right so this is good keys and what
are bad Keys intuitively bad keys are
the keys which don't encrypt the same
message but the pro verifies and those
are very easy to sample you like encrypt
garbage and if you have a what is called
simulation tror foric for those of you
who know simulation tror allows you to
proof arbitrary kind of you know valid
proofs for arbitrary junk uh so
intuitively it will allow it to be to to
to to give proofs of false statements
okay so this is a syntax of the
construction we are far from done but
this is a syntax of the construction
okay so and distinguishing how do you
distinguish them well if I give you two
secret Keys you can distinguish you just
decrypt and check if the messages are
the same all right so anyway this is a
syntax okay good um now we just need to
briefly argue these properties and it
turns out some of them will be actually
not that complicated so let's start with
a simple property almost a trivial
property which is a hardness properties
right so this is a scheme I'm sorry just
trust me it's the same scheme
you know encryption of a random message
encryption of random message and the
proof so I claim that if1 is just
semantically secure even one by secure
and Pi is a sound proof you cannot prove
all statements the scheme has this
hardness look assume I'm giving you a
trap to generate good keys so you have
the message and the randomness right and
you need to produce a bad key what is a
bad key it means that you need to
encrypt a different message and fake a
proof well but that means you fake a
proof you you produce the proof of a
false statement that should be hard
right so given you knowand it should be
very hard for you to fake the proof
soundness of an easy now if I give you a
way to generate fake proofs of orbitary
statement doesn't really matter um how
can you produce a good proof well a good
proof it means that I encrypted a random
message I give you encryption of a
random message now what you need to do
you need to produce a different
encryption of the same message well but
if you produce a different encryption of
the same message it means that you
inverted the you know the encryption
because I can just decrypt it and
yeah
if the adversary has MNR and the key has
the encryption key why can't he just
encrypt the same the Vance seat remember
this keys I'm sorry this keys are just
mental experiments so I just need to
tell you how to do a key generation so
that I simultanously also generate this
a way to sim to sample a random good key
a way to sample a random bad key and
this so adversary I mean in some of the
properties adversary will get this
key sorry okay
or is he actually getting M&R so it
depends on which property so in the
property of hardness of good keys of
hardness of bad keys he will get M&R so
he will get M&R but his job is to forge
a bad key what does it mean to forge a
get key it means that he has to produce
encryption of a different
massm and approves that verifies but he
has the publicy he has M&R and he has a
public key
sure but he has to encrypt it has to be
a bad key of course he can encrypt a you
know am again and produce a good proof
but then encs a bad message why can't he
oh cuz he can't make a proof yeah
because yeah he doesn't know the trap
door to the CRS so this is he only gets
a sample a good sampling key he cannot
produce a bad thing okay to he on the
other hand he will actually get the Trap
so that he can fake proves but his job
is to produce a good key and that
intuitively means that he has to encrypt
decrypt E1 he has to break encryption if
you want right so these two properties
yeah why cannot see just like bring
encryp
so what so intuitively well because if
he re encrypts it means that he
decrypted the first encryption because I
give you encryption of a random message
I don't tell you you produce a different
encryption of the same message right uh
I don't care if it you know the trapdor
and some proof but it has to be of the
same message under different public here
so it means that look you could have in
the first in the reduction to the
security of E1 I can just choose a
public secret key for the second
encryption scheme you produce an
encryption of this thing I decrypt it
and I break the first encryption scheme
right so these are like really simple
properties and so um now uh you know I'm
going to do the randomization so this is
something where we start to need to make
serious assumptions yeah sorry yeah of
course of course if you go back to the
uh to the hardness of the Bad Keys say
the public key encryption scheme happens
to homomorphic then
sure he creates a CER text which is a
new CER text but it's an encryption of
the same message and he has a track but
it's a different public key so E1 and E2
have completely independent public keys
so this is not it's not like I'm using
the same Ean and you know it's not like
I'm I I use two completely independent
encryption schem so what I'm saying is
if you can do it doesn't matter if it's
homomorphic or not in fact our schemes
will have to be homomorphic I just break
encryption so I get a challenge
encryption of a random message I pick
public key secret key for the second
scheme myself I give you that as a
public key you produce a second
encryption of the same message I decrypt
it and say oh great I break I broke my
first thing good so um randomization so
now I will need to assume some special
properties and if you think about it
what is our secret key it's a secret key
our secret key is a cipher Tex and a
proof so I need to randomize the cipher
text and the proof so randomizing Cipher
text as you said many encryptions will
do it in fact if encryption is what is
called homeomorphic it's very easy to
randomize a certic so many standard
encryption scheme proof is a little bit
weird because after we randomiz C2 the
statement for the proof changes the
first in Cipher text remained in the
public key but the second I just
refreshed so I need to kind of make sure
that I need to update a niic proof niic
for some old statement to a niic for a
fresh niic for a new statement so that
will be kind of not
trivial um so here is what we going to
assume we're going to assume that the
one two and Pi are homomorphic of
appropriate groups so for encryption
homomorphic is essentially natural these
three pluses are different you know they
don't have to be the same but intui it
just means that if you just add two
encryptions up it's like encryption of
some of the messages some of the
randomness and essentially any
encryption you study in the first course
like mik gal for appropriate meanings of
plus will have this property so this is
yeah what does this update updating
music use obviously if you have a
witness for the new statement you're
done so this is the next two bullets so
let me let me discuss it but a great
question yeah this is like the new the
novel stuff right I mean it's like how
do you know you have a EIC for one
statement now you refresh the statement
yourself and you need to update the
proof so this is tricky how you can do
it so it turns out at least a syntax
just to make sure how is it even
possible without breaking the soundness
of mic so it turns out that the music
that we will use will be NS for
homomorphic languages so what does it
mean it's a homomorphic language it
means that if you have two valid
instances X Plus X Prime is also in the
language so there are natural languages
which homomorphic in this and in
particular we will see one and I claim
that a homomorphic music for homomorphic
language it means that if you have two
proofs pi and Pi primes are proof for
two statements x and x Prime if you add
up the proofs you simultan you right
away get a proof for X Plus X Prime
which luckily is in the
language so it's kind of this notion
only makes sense for H morphic languages
because otherwise you break sound but
luckily because look these are valid
inputs so they have proof you add them
up it's still a valid thing so there is
no contradiction that you can get a
proof for a valid statement SOS only
says that you cannot get proofs for fake
statement stat so this is just you know
this is just a syntax that shows that
it's conceivable to have this
homomorphic properties
right and uh this is really inspired
this notion is really inspired by a
paper of Mira and Melissa um uh which
used uh which you know we use the fact U
you know randomizable and malleable NS
we kind of have to go just a bit you
know one step fasther that we even
change the statements in some sense but
um anyway so it turns out that once the
point is that if you have both
encryption schemes are homomorphic which
is easy to satisfy by itself the
language of they both encrypt the same
thing is easily homomorphic it's easy to
see that you know if these two guys
encryp the same messages and another two
guys encryp the same messages you add
them up they both encryp the sum of
those two messages so this is Tri a
homomorphic language and now I claim
it's very easy to at least the statement
it's very easy to randomize it's
actually very easy to randomize the
whole thing if you have homomorphic
nesic and homomorphic encryption schemes
syntactically here is how I randomize it
so C1 is part of the public I'm not
allowed to touch it so this should be
encryptions of the same message so I
will randomize it I will let a random
encryption of zero okay well but let's
look at the resulting Cipher text I can
write it also as C1 C2 plus encryption
of 0 0 encryption of z r right I mean
this is just because encryption is
homomorphic so for this I have the proof
for this statement I have the proof but
I don't have any Witnesses I don't know
any
but here this is essentially an
encryption of zero for which I know the
witness what is the witness it's zero R
R I chose myself right so essentially
the new statement I got is the old
statement plus a statement for which I
know the witness so what I can do I can
generate a fresh niic for this statement
add it to the old niic and I get a valid
niic so this is just syntactically that
if I have this properties I can
randomize syntactically stuff okay
sootch tells me that I should uh uh
finish soon and okay maybe like 3
minutes I'll skip a lot of things so any
this was like the important thing and
okay well so this is actually okay so
maybe like three minutes on the most
important property this is kind of the
key new property that we get so this is
at least we managed to show that if we
have this magic things we can have um
this property is now the novel property
and intuitively the novel property needs
something from E2 because I used
everything else right I used uh you know
properties of encryption scheme1 I used
the sound and so on uh but I didn't uh
uh you know use anything about it to and
it turns out if you just run the
definition of lickage and
distinguishability here is a new
security property from E2 that you need
so this is a security property it's very
cute as you'll see it's precisely in
between Chosen plantic and chosen cyhex
security so the property is this that
given intuitively bits of leakage over
the cipher Tex so usually you see the
challenge Cipher Tex here if you don't
only see some partial information about
the challenge cerx you cannot uh produce
a related Cipher T So formally the
adversary gets public key he chooses two
messages Challenger increases one of
them but instead of giving the full cyer
Tex to the attacker the adversary gets
only L bits of lickage on the cipher
text so you cannot see the entire Cipher
text the attacker has essentially
produces another cyer C prime it makes
the decryption query on this C Prime and
he wins if decryption of C primes is is
equal to B right so it's not very hard
so we call it l leakage of CER Tex non
Mal liability
so intuitively it's kind of you know
it's kind of a weird notion and it turns
out it's not very hard to see that it
lies is precisely in between Chosen
plantic and chosen Cypher security just
kind of this is kind of cute this
direction why does it lead here because
if the scheme is even one leakage
nonmalleable secure so you can say look
assume the scheme is not chosen plantic
secure how do I break this well I look
at the CER Tex I I have a distinguisher
who you know distinguishes encryption of
zero of encryption of one that's that's
my leakage function I look at the cipher
Tex I just leak the bid with it's
encryption of 01 and I break the scheme
and I just reencrypt let's say 01 so
it's kind of trivial that uh this notion
implies chosen pling security it's a
little bit less trivial but also in two
minutes you can see that uh nonability
implies this and the challenge of course
is you can say oh great just use nonm
valuable encryption but remember we need
our encryptions to be homeomorphic right
encryption two has to be homomorphic for
the syntax and this is a new property
that we need so the question is is it
POS to have this thing so CPA is trival
to do homomorphic right but it's not
probably going to be leakage non
malleable this is leakage non malleable
but it cannot provably be homomorphic
can I do something in between okay and
this is kind of uh so anyway this is a
summary maybe I'll skip but essentially
we show that everything will work out if
we have E1 E2 and Pi which are
homomorphic and E2 has this Noel
property and uh okay in one minute I'll
wrap up maybe a so it's very nontrivial
to instantiate those things I just
wanted to give you a sum of this
construction so luckily homomorphic e
there is this paper of gross s High
which happens to be homomorphic it's
just beautiful paper but it's only for
restricted classes of languages but
likely this classes of languages are
power powerful enough for us um it's
secure under the SK linear assumption
that's why we stuck with SK line
assumption so this is a magic box that
essentially you know uh pushes the
things through but there is a lot of
other work as as you see we need to be
done anyway this is a reasonable
assumption so I will not too homomorphic
encryption Ean is trial just use Gamal
encryption or you know it's easy to
generalize it for K linear so I forgot
so Kine for k equals one is just ddh
assumption so let's just assume ddh
assumption uh and for it two it turns
out that we can use crammer shl
encryption so for those of you know who
crar so there is a full crar sh
encryption which is not homomorphic in
because there is this component which
you know it's like hash of something and
it cannot be holomorphic because CCA 2
there is a cca1 version of kar which is
crammer shli which is easily homomorphic
there is no weird components you can
just multiply those RS just propagate
but it's only CC One Security in general
it doesn't imply leage nonability but if
you look at the proof uh I mean I'm not
going to tell you inition but it's not
very hard in 2 minutes I would be able
to tell you intuition it's just you know
the directly the easy adaptation of crar
show proof shows that it has this
incomparable property of uh liage and
marable security and it gives you
leakage one quarter but you can kind of
add more elements in the public key and
you can get like oneus Epson leakage
normal liability so anyway to conclude
so this is what we have uh at the end we
constructed a leakage resilient One Way
relation based on K linear assumption
the leakage is roughly speaking one over
k + one depending but you know the
assumption is better so the highest K
the lower the leakage but the more
believable the assumption is and it's
really practical efficient there is a
constant number of group elements well
constant maybe like 40 but you know it's
a constant but I mean it's there is no
pcps no cookle reductions or anything
like that and uh and this application as
I said using heavily using prior work
adapted to continuous leakage setting
the show how to build the scheme and
even it's that was actually very
surprising especially for signatures
that we could actually preserve
efficiency so this was actually a highly
known trial bullet but you know it's
only one bullet but there was a lot of
work in this bullet um and okay I will
not mention I'll talk offline about
leakage during key update we kind of
observe following implicit observation
of um this very nice paper of we not
that if you have a scheme which is air
leakage resilient without any leakage
during key updates you can kind of trade
one bit of leakage during key updates
for one bit of leakage inside ke update
but unfortunately you pay a factor of
two the K in Security in the running
time of the
attacker uh and this is uh it's a very
cute but it's totally trivial
observation if you think about it
corollary is
that if you have an L liage resilience
scheme in the cute setting it's
automatically it can terate other log of
security parameter leakage during key
update so um so the model is unless you
break this barrier which is a very
difficult question it's a great open
question to allow higher leakage during
key updates but unless you can break
this barrier don't even buzzer with a
more complicated model just do a clean
beautiful model which is already
complicated you know and then
automatically for free get security this
leakage during key updates but this is a
very practically important thing so it's
actually very important uh that our
schemes or any other scheme that you can
come up in the future will satisfy this
property for encryption signatures
anything you want so this is kind of for
free okay uh we have other extensions uh
leakage of Randomness during computation
you know all of them are non-trivial but
it turns out that our scheme happens to
satisfy them with some work um so for
example during signing for one varation
there is no Randomness you know no local
Randomness it's just you have a secret
key you verify but if you sign messages
you know the signatures could be
probabilistic so maybe not only your
secret key leaks but the randomness
during signing leaks of for key
agreement you choose G to a g to the B
maybe those guy Le and so on right so uh
it turns out that with some nonrival
work uh we managed to do it but
unfortunately our signature uh and ID uh
ID sorry our ID schemes in AKA are only
sorry signatures in AK only in the
random Oracle model ID schem in the
standard model so uh and you know there
is some there are some more extensions
uh so there is a very nice paper of the
not which uh unfortunately he's not
going to talk about here but it shows
how to extend uh uh I mean it's totally
different scheme you know beautiful
techniques but they also show how to get
continuous leage resilient public
encryption and even like more advanced
stuff like IB uh and it leads also to an
alternative construction of continuous
leakage resilience oneway relation and
signatures uh ironically and implicitly
even though they had like a very long
like 50 page you know proof of this kind
of thing
uh implicitly there uh they also build a
l so some some implicitly they even
though they do encryption but if you
look at the publicy secret key relation
it also builds a new uh leakage and
distinguishable randomizable relation uh
and ironically it's you know it's very
different technique but they use the
same assumptions they don't use
explicitly gross the high proofs but the
algebra they use you know it's based on
the same assumptions there is some magic
that from very different angles um you
know we came up uh with the same schema
and even the scheme it's also very nice
the scheme actually has better leakage
one overk as opposed to one overk plus
one that we have and this is kind of the
observation that we have improving a
slightly you know a v bound that they
originally had so anyway so this is
state of Art and uh I'm sorry you know
the paper is available on
in let's than the
speaker running over time so that off
offine the break and then we'll resume
at when does
uh 6 minutes 6 minutes oh boy 10 minutes
okay
than